now thank you
[Music]
ready when you are okay good evening
everybody and welcome
to tonight's uh virtual planning
committee a it's the 19th of august six
o'clock
and we are about to start so uh my name
is councillor richards i will be
chairing
uh the meeting this evening uh members a
little bit of housekeeping to start with
you
should all have been provided now uh
with the council's etiquette for virtual
meetings in advance of this meeting
to reiterate a few of the main points
please could you ensure
that your device is either plugged in
and charging or is already fully charged
just in case we lose you
uh please remember to mute your
microphones before oh sorry when you ask
me
your microphones when you're not
speaking forgive me and remember to
unmute them
when you're about to start speaking when
you do start speaking if you could
please say your name first and then
carry on with with whatever it is you
want
you are wanting to say um to make sure
we
maintain uh a fluid meeting if you could
please indicate
that you want to speak through the chat
function uh i will have that open and
i'll be able to see when you're
indicating there so i will call you in
at the right time
um again if you could also please make
sure any other devices are either
switched off or switched to silent
um so that we don't have any
interruptions throughout the proceedings
if for any reason you do encounter it
issues um
causing you to drop out then of the
meeting then if you could please make
every effort to get back in as soon as
you possibly can
provided we are still corrupt we will
continue with the meeting
um and if you're unable to join for any
reason uh if you you would have been
deemed to have left the meeting at that
point
um there will be two numbers put into
the chat for you uh
for democratic services and um the it
team
that will be able to help you get back
in if you're having any
uh further issues uh do remember as well
that the meeting is being broadcast live
and that members of the public are able
to view all of the proceedings
uh for for members of the public and
observers um
just to confirm that prior to uh in the
five minutes prior to the meeting
starting
in front of our count the council's
legal officer we did
speak to all members of the committee to
confirm that they can
see and hear all of the proceedings and
they have read all of the relevant
paperwork so we we have had that
confirmed by all members
also present online with us um our
officers from democratic services that
is olivia quinn
liz jaworska and anne banks we also have
a legal officer mina mack
and our planning officers are richard
gardner who is our planning manager for
the evening
louise coleman eddie wrench sarah
macpherson and sarah chanwick
okay so um if we get straight on into
the main agenda at this point um could i
please ask if there have been any
apologies
for absence
thank you chairman we've had apologies
from councillor jennings and kendall
fantastic thank you and do we have any
disclosures of interest
i will give you a couple of seconds
members to write in the chat
if you do counselor adam
would you like to thank jeremy um i just
have to disclose
that i'll be speaking as ward member on
item
um land off stockton road so i'll be uh
stepping down from the committee for
that application okay lovely thank you
and councillor edin
thank you chair uh similarly i'll be on
the ward member for item number five and
i'll be speaking on
that application so we'll be doing the
same
okay lovely thank you um i see no one
else uh writing
in the chat at this point so i shall
assume that is all of the disclosures of
interest
um there are no minutes for me to sign
so we can go straight into our first
application that is application nineteen
zero zero seven three one f u l corner
of waterloo road and wellington road in
bidford upon avon
uh louise coleman is our presenting
officer louise over to you
thank you chair all right
can everyone see this screen
weekend yeah okay sorry just making sure
okay right um
the application site is identified by
the black dot on the map
and is located approximately half a mile
north of the village center of bidford
and avon
with stratford-upon-avon being
approximately six miles to the east and
eastham
being approximately six miles to the
southwest
the application site is identified by
the site edged in red is located within
the built-up area boundary of biddeford
and ivan village
the site comprises approximately 1.1
hectares of brownfield land
which historically operates in
industrial facilities but been vacant
for approximately 15 years
and the buildings have been demolished
the site is accessed from wellington
road to the north
and waterloo road to the west and it
sits in the prominent location adjacent
to the junction of
waterloo road and wellington road beyond
the site northern and eastern boundaries
are commercial and industrial units
forming past the larger waterloo
road industrial estate residential
properties adjoin the southern boundary
and also lie on the opposite side of the
waterloo road to the west
the proposal seeks to erect 50 new
affordable dwellings on the site
the layout proposed respond to the
pattern of development characteristics
of the area with the public front of the
dwellings facing onto the public highway
within both waterloo road and wellington
road with side and back boundaries
abutting onto each other
access to the site involves the creation
of a new vehicular access
off uh waterloo road and a private
access point supposed
to be created to serve the dwellings
fronting onto wellington road
a leap is also proposed in a central
position of putting the northern
boundary
with footpath linkages onto wellington
road
existing hedgerows along the rear so the
southern part of the site are proposed
to be retained together with the willow
tree fronting onto waterloo road
which i'll show you shortly in some
photographs
in terms of street scenes the design and
form of the dwellings
draw upon the local vernacular they will
be constructed
primarily of brick with some use of
render and contrasting roof tiles as you
can see
ridge heights are also proposed to be
varied to provide greater interest
and would also comprise of mix of one
bed to four bed dwellings with a
reindeer
range of tenure of shared ownership
social rent
and affordable rent the development
requires the inclusion of three meter
high acoustic wool and fencing
primarily along uh wellington road
frontage in order to
ensure noise mitigation levels are
secured
um in addition levels do vary through
the sites by
approximately a meter and um 1.2 meters
from the front to the southeastern
corner of the site and i can expand on
this
um later if required in terms of
typical elevations i've put up a couple
of pictures
of some of the house types um so that
was one of the brick and one of the
uh rendered part rendered here
now looking at some photographs of the
site so this is looking
along waterloo road just using the arrow
here
so this is waterloo road this is
wellington road
the dwellings to the rear here are new
um well relatively new development
copenhagen way
um with the retain proposed to be
retained um
willow tree
again this is just another photograph
within the site
looking towards a southeastern corner
where there's slightly higher levels
uh the levels of the dwellings uh in
copenhagen way
because this is um falling land uh
falling away to wellington road so they
are slightly higher
than the application site
this is a view looking down wellington
road
um so this is the industrial park pro
plant being located on the other side of
the road here
a tool a higher place uh opposite
and then this is a view of the access
where this is silver birch which isn't
worthy of protection
um that the willow tree is being
retained however isn't
just been noting it is not worthy of tpo
but
it is proposed to be retained as part of
the scheme
together with further enhancement of the
frontage with
additional tree planting as seen in the
layout plan
um and uh that's the end of my
presentation chair
oh sorry what sorry one final point is
that there are a number of
updates within the update uh sheet um
which obviously members need to take a
moment to
to update themselves with um uh there
are
some comments from councillor pemberton
which need to be taken on board
um and uh recommendation chair
is to grant subject to the
conditions within the committee report
and
if i refer you to the update sheet there
are a couple of amendments proposed two
uh conditions um uh
which is on on the page three of the
update sheet
um so amending the wording of condition
three
and uh proposing to delete condition 20
um in addition the recommendation is is
proposing to amend the wording
of um reference to 35
affordable housing to 100 affordable
housing
and the addition of a 6 000 pound
traffic regulation order
contribution within the recommendation
um
and that's um that concludes my
presentation thank you chair
louise thank you very much that was
excellent okay so if we move to our
first speakers then
um uh so for all speakers benefits um
you
certainly for our first speaker will
have three minutes we will give uh
30 seconds warning before the time is up
for each of our speakers
um once you've finished if you could
please hang on the line uh some members
may have questions for you
our first speaker is elizabeth aguiles
from on behalf of the parish council
elizabeth are you there you may need to
press star six to unmute yourself
can you hear me we can good evening
welcome
good evening so whenever you're ready as
i say you've got three minutes and we'll
give you a 30 second warning
okay good evening councillors
the parish council and many residents
strongly object to this application for
50 affordable dwellings
on the basis that it is not sustainable
and contrary to the bitterness and ndp
econ 1 policy which aims to protect and
enhance existing employment sites such
as this popular industrial
estate policy econ 1 clearly states that
the sustainability of bitford on avon is
dependent upon the opportunity of local
people to find
local employment over the past five
years
permission has been granted for the
development of more than 700 dwellings
all with a 35 affordable housing element
it is therefore of paramount importance
that this committee consider the ndp
econ 1 policy
when addressing this application which
aims to convert
a very contaminated brownfield on an
industrial estate
into a development of affordable housing
which does not
meet local needs on a very busy road
according to the housing needs survey
carried out on behalf of the parish
council in october 2017
the need for 42 affordable dwellings was
identified
many of them bungalows which are being
provided by miller home development
with the other requirements being met by
our developments and i can tell you that
if
from 2017 to now 125
affordable dwellings therefore there
would appear to be no further
requirement in bitfoot for affordable
housing
whereas there would appear to be a need
for local employment for the many new
residents of the parish
if there is a need for affordable
housing within the district
perhaps it can look elsewhere than at
the over developed village of bitford
and let sites within the industrial
areas remain commercial folks
in this particular instance the parish
council is aware of the successful
business within this industrial estate
that would like to expand but will leave
if this site is developed as residential
furthermore the council also disputes
the validity of the marketing study
carried out by the applicant
this committee should also be aware that
when the inspector granted permission
for the miller homes development on
lounge to the west of waterloo road
i was 200 dwellings he or she took into
account the fact that this site was
allocated as a supermarket this does
beggar the question as to whether that
development would have gone ahead
otherwise
the parish council requests this
committee to consider the local needs of
bitford
which are economic and not residential
over the years we have witnessed the
closure
of many shops in the high street the
doctor's surgery has moved to a site in
the outskirts of the village
the sole bank has closed and the post
office that's the second
chairman this benefit cannot sustain a
further erosion of its
economy nor can it sustain a further
increase of its rapidly raising
population
on this basis please refuse permission
thank you for listening elizabeth that
was fantastic thank you very much
perfect timing
members do you have any questions um i
have
ann parry councillor parry has indicated
council parry
thank you chairman and uh good evening
everybody i wonder whether the
uh parish councillor could just advise
has the applicant been in consultation
with you during this process
and also do you happen to know
how many people in bidford might be on a
waiting list
for an affordable home and thirdly if i
may chairman
are there any um affordable
only sites within bidford is
or is this completely a unique situation
to have a totally
soulless affordable site okay can i just
first clarify i'm the clock not a
counsellor oh i'm sorry
no that's all right that's not a problem
um
they did consult some time ago it's a
long time when the first came to present
it
um but that was it um then
i don't know how many people are on the
waiting list i have to admit
sorry i can see you i i don't know how
many people that are on the waiting list
as i said we the parish council did
carry out a housing needs
survey back in october 17 and there were
42
requirements at that time of which 125
have been built so that's
nearly three times or just three times
so um i'm sure that um stratford
um would be able to give you the figures
if there's anybody in bitford
waiting list and no we don't have um
any any uh particular well we do in
broome have something which was
affordable housing
but not a hundred percent affordable on
the other hand we have had a lot of
new developments and all i thought that
35 allocation
okay thank you thank you very much both
i don't see any other questions i'm
going to give counselors another couple
of seconds in case they wanted to chuck
in a
an extra question doesn't look like it
so elizabeth thank you very much
um you are free to to go what do i do
now do i have to do anything
if you hang up you'll be able to watch
the rest of the the committee through
the online portal
okay thank you very much thank you very
much
okay so if you move to our second
speaker which um i have listed as
councillor bill fleming
councillor fleming are you there you may
need to press star six again to
unmute yourself
counselor fleming are you uh are you
able to hear us
star six to one yeah i think i think i'm
clear now is that okay
we've got you now yes thank you very
much um same rules apply three minutes
we'll give you a thirty second warning
uh whenever you're ready
please do start okay right
uh good evening chairman and committee
i'm bill fleming a joining sdc member
for this application
and chair of bidford parish council
planning committee i'm here to
strenuously object to this application
for several i consider very valid
reasons
the proposed development that does not
meet any local housing need
the last one identified a number of
dwellings and since then we've had two
major developments and one medium-sized
development
adjacent to this site all these have
adhered to the requirements for
affordable housing
and as you've just heard we've got three
times more than we needed
a number of these are as yet unless
affordable houses are not universally
popular in bidford
we do not have a local need a primary
school to school bar a couple of places
in years two and three
a large number of reception class
children are scattered over several
schools
in neighbouring villages every secondary
school child is bus
to ulster and our high street is
virtually dead so this village is really
struggling
the mini roundabout where this
development residence will emerge from
was constructed for the industrial
estate in 150 houses of traffic
since then we've had an additional 314
houses built
that use that roundabout i'm sure
workshop county council highways have a
model that says everything is fine
but reality is very different from
models possibly the biggest argument to
stop this proposed development
is it will remove all of the remaining
industrial stroke commercial land for
development we have we have an ndp that
states industry development
is vital to the sustainability of the
village's future
it's been an industrial commercial site
for almost 60 years
albeit derelict for the last 10 or so as
planning chair for the bidford parish
council i've had several conversations
with the ceo of one of the villages
major high profile employers
they are a tier one motorsport
competition company with a production
facility for specialized motor products
he told him that if he cannot expand
within the village
he would take his company elsewhere
probably to reddit's
and take the 50 jobs with him he tried
to purchase this land for a price
reflecting its industrial usage
but couldn't stroke wouldn't meet the
seller's inflated price
as he is counting on getting housing
permission
this land selling price is 637 000
pounds per acre
industrial land five miles away is less
than 40 percent of that asking price
and this land has been priced for houses
hence why it's never sold for industry
finally we have a climate emergency that
we declared last summer so
if the supermarket hadn't been scared
off by the inflated price
a proportion of the 600 houses at that
end of the village could shop locally
if we had another 50 houses that 50 more
will use a car to go shopping
despite the needs for the 50 family to
drive to work as we have no local
housing need
for the new resident and so the new
residents will come from outside the
village and work elsewhere
please refuse this unnecessary
development it would add nothing to the
community and put pressure on a village
that's had no infrastructure expansion
for 30 years
maybe if you're reminded not to refuse
at this time further investigation on
the selling price
and the efforts to market this run
properly as industrial commercially
a deferral option may have fully opened
up the facts thank you very much
council fleming thank you very much uh
we if you could stay on the line we do
have a question for you councillor parry
when you're ready
thank you chairman good evening
councillor fleming um
i just wonder whether you could just
confirm how many years it took the
parish
to develop the neighborhood development
plan and what the percentage
of residents um voted yes
for this plan and therefore obviously
your economic policies it just be
helpful to get a bit of a feel
for the response to your neighborhood
development plan
yes certainly our neighborhood plan was
made
just have to rely on my memory now about
three years ago
it took two possibly three years to put
it together
and it was a very well put together
document and
we had a 94 approval on it so you know
people were very happy with what we were
offering and
and they came to vote and and gave us
their decision
lovely thank you very much for that um
councillors do we have any further
questions for councillor fleming let me
just give you a couple of seconds
i will take that as a no so council
farming thank you very much for your
time
um thank you for you to go when when you
wish
um okay so we'll move to our next we
will move to our next speaker then um
our next speaker is
sam silcox who i believe is the agent
for the applicant
mr silcox are you there you may need to
press star 6 to unmute yourself
uh good evening can you hear me uh we
can yes
welcome man good thing thank you so mr
silcox you have six minutes
um and again we will give you a
30-second uh warning towards
the end and if you can stay on the line
for any questions that would be great
whenever you're ready please begin
thank you well good evening members um
my name is sam silcox i'm a director at
harris land planning consultancy
and as highlighters i'm here to speak on
behalf of the applicant and we would
like to start
by confirming our support for your
officer's recommendation to grant
planning permission
for the residential development of this
site the positive recommendation
presented by officers is supported by a
full set of positive consultation
responses
which includes the independent review of
the applicant's marketing report
and the independent review of the design
of the proposal as commissioned by the
council
the proposal would deliver 50 affordable
dwellings this is a significant
contribution towards the demand for
affordable housing in the district
the site has been vacant for over a
decade despite attempts to secure its
development
and the proposal provides the
opportunity to rectify this
bidford is confirmed to be a sustainable
location to deliver housing
by both the core strategy and the bid
for native neighborhood neighborhood
plan
policy h4 of the neighborhood plan
confirms that the redevelopment of
brownfield sites for housing will be
supported
the proposal has also been changed
comply with the policies
in the course strategy and the
neighborhood plan that deal with the
release of former employment sites to
alternative uses
this has been confirmed by offices and
the independent review of the
applicant's marketing report by addison
young
on behalf of the council the independent
review from anderson young also
concludes there was no retail demand for
the site this not withstanding
it is important to highlight there is no
planning policy basis
for considering the retail developed
demand for this site
because there are no policies in the
core strategy or neighborhood plan
that seek to designate or protect this
site for retail use
so whilst it's been clearly demonstrated
there's no retail demand
this is not a matter which would
influence the determination of this
application
in relation to the technical and design
matters relevant to the determination of
this application
we would like to highlight that the
proposal in front of members is a result
of detailed negotiations with officers
and consultants
for example the discussions with the
county council of the highway authority
led to changes the internal road design
the number of parking spaces being
provided
and the proposal for parking
restrictions on wellington road
and the highway authorities confirmed
these changes have addressed all their
comments
in summary the proposal delivers a high
quality residential scheme on this
vacant previously developed site
which will make a significant
contribution towards the demand for
affordable housing in the district
the local development plan confirms this
is a sustainable location to deliver
housing
and there is support across the board
from your offices and consulting
we therefore respectfully request the
planning commission be granted in
accordance with your office's
recommendation
silcox thank you very much that is well
within your time limit um very much
appreciated
um do we have any questions for mr
silcox councillor parry
maybe to you you will need to unmute
yourself councillor perry
thank you chairman sorry it's me again
um i would be very interested to know i
happen to do a little bit of research on
the
current status of shared ownership
properties in the district
and i note there are over 20 properties
available
on the home choice plus scheme across
the district that
have been advertised for the last year i
just wonder whether the applicant's
agent can explain um his views on the
demand
for shared ownership that is
one particular question i would like to
have an answer to
and also um i was interested to know
um his client has often built
open market schemes with a mix of tenure
and i just would be interested to know
um why this has come forward as a
hundred percent affordable homes
in one particular area um when in
particular cs 18
promotes on-site integration of
affordable homes that you don't have
them all in one cluster
thank you chairman
um okay uh well thank you for those
questions councillor parry um
uh i think the intern answered his first
question about the um
demand for shared ownership i think it's
probably worth um just going back and
pointing out that this is an application
which has been submitted between
countryside as the house builder but
it's in partnership
with midland heart of the affordable
housing provider
so the scheme has been worked up with
the affordable housing provider
using their knowledge of demand in the
market for affordable housing and
in terms of what they were looking for
in terms of an end product
and i think through that um through
those discussions with middle and hearts
the mix
um has been determined um but
they've also been discussions during the
application and the mix was changed
to address the comments from the
council's housing officer
um so i think in in answer the question
i think the midland heart wouldn't be
looking to take on these units
within the mix proposed if they didn't
consider there to be a need
for them or they didn't think they'd be
able to in the case of shared ownership
sell them to the market um
into answers to the second question um
i i think it's probably similar to the
first really in the sense that
um the reason it's come forward as it
has is because it's being delivered in
partnership with an affordable housing
provider
and it does provide a mix of 10 unions
within the affordable sphere so we
we've got a mixture in here um we've got
social rent we've got affordable rent
and we have shared ownership and
assurance ship is a purchase you know is
a product to buy
and it's just a way of those who can't
perhaps access a traditional mortgage
from accessing the housing lad and
providing them a step on
um so within that context we do have
quite a
mix of units and i think it is worth
remember reminding ourselves as well
this is in the residential area
and there are a range of market units
locally and waiting to take as a whole
this unit this scheme would integrate
well with the existing position
and provide that mix of uses that would
otherwise be looked to be achieved
lovely thank you very much um council
adam has a question for you
thank you chairman um it was just in
relation to the
um marketing um
survey that was carried out by haverson
young which i believe
was submitted as part of the application
um
obviously some concerns were raised by
speakers so far as to the pricing of the
land
uh and and the way in which it was
marketed effectively pricing people out
to reduce um interest can
can you confirm that this was considered
by the
survey that was carried out and if not
why
um no of course absolutely um past
the act the application the survey
wasn't actually submitted by abison
young um
havis and young were um they were
instructed by the council to do an
independent review
of the survey we had submitted by the
marketing agent for the site
um so when we when we were putting the
application together we spoke to the
marketing agent who
was acting for the landowner um they've
been involved in the site over the years
um in its previous sort of connotations
and various attempts to get it onto the
market
um so different stages and they've
marketed it
for employment in the first instance
then for retail when the retail content
was in place
and then more recently for you know it
was an open-ended sort of marketing
process
um as part of that process you're
absolutely right
we have to demonstrate that um there was
marketed an appropriate value to give
a reasonable opportunity for the
existing youth to
uh to continue i say existing use that's
the historic use of an employment
operator
um and it was confirmed through the
independent review that
um yes that was an incorrect way it
wasn't over inflated
and the price was reflective of the
market at the time
lovely thank you and councillor fitter
you have a question
oh yeah yeah um so according to
the parish council there was the
suggestion that the site is contaminated
do you know what it is contaminated with
and what the plans are to sort it out
um i i don't have full details of what's
contaminated but yes it is contaminated
to a point um it there has been
uh detailed ground investigations to
establish
um what's in the ground uh and that will
lead into
a full detailed remediation scheme which
i believe is one of the conditions
we have to submit that detail and ensure
not only do we agree
the nature of the remediation with the
council but that that the um
the success of that is verified down the
line before the site can be occupied
um so that is fundamental to what we're
doing here um so one thing i can say is
it's not a it's not a heavily
contaminated site
um so some of the sites i've worked on
elsewhere it's
um when you've had other sort of uses
like former tips and things for example
it's nowhere in that sort of region
i don't know it's actually realm it's
it's all relatively
uh sort of straightforward
run-of-the-mill sort of stuff when it
comes to housing schemes and
um there are measures in place to make
sure that the proper process is followed
to ensure
uh an acceptable living standard for
residents going forwards
lovely thank you i do believe we've got
a condition to clear any land
contamination is conditioned 16
uh within the report um i have a final
question for you mr silcox if you
if i may um the land has been uh left as
a redundant industrial building and hard
standing
uh for quite some time i understand can
you give us an indication as to how long
it's been
in in its current state um
there's something we've had to sort of
piece together um the earliest back i
can know that i know
that the building wasn't there was in
2008 i believe
um how long before that the site was
breaking i'm not 100 clear i have to be
honest but um
it's been in excess of a decade um
that's lovely that that answers my
question lovely thank you very much
um members are there any other questions
for mr silcox at this point
i will take that as a no so uh mr zilcox
thank you very much for your your time
your contribution um you're free to go
and or
if you want to hang on and listen to
deliberations you're more than welcome
to do that
as well okay so remember
thank you very much um if we now move
into any technical questions
uh points of clarification with the
officers does anyone have any points for
clarification
they would like to make at this point
chairman are we hearing from the i
do apologize i'm
counsellor pemberton i've i can't
believe i forgot you
you are actually written down and i did
forget um cancer penalty
richards i can't believe that you forgot
me either i
know i'm so sorry um so you have
you have five minutes and we'll give you
a 30-second uh warning before your time
is up so
whenever you are ready please do go
ahead
uh so before i begin members will have
seen um
a number of comments i have put forward
in the update sheet which
relate to reasons for refusals with
policy substantiation which are
i would like you to consider in addition
to the comments i'm about to make
so i'm just about to set my own watch
off and uh to kick off
good evening members this may well be
the most significant planning decision
many of you
will ever make at stake is nothing less
than the continued sustainability of
bidford
and in terms of how we as a planning
authority shape place
and create real communities the
application is presented as reusing
brownfield land with no employment or
commercial use to provide affordable
housing
that's not the actual case the loss of
this site for employment and retail will
reinforce biddeford's position as the
largest dormitory car dependent
housing estate in warwickshire we would
not build bidford from scratch this way
it's not anybody's fault but a mixture
of a previous lack of five-year land
supply and appeals
has meant pidford is now the size of
ulster with retail and employment
facilities akin to a local
service village don't believe me well as
at yesterday the number of tank council
tax accounts in ulster was 3016.
in bidford it is 2899 a difference of
117
and even before tonight's application
there are still approximately 130 homes
still to be built out in biddeford
there comes a point where the weight of
housing development in the imbalance of
other facilities and infrastructure will
make any settlement
unsustainable as decision makers there
is sufficient evidence before you
tonight
to legitimately come to the conclusion
that this point has been reached in
pittford
there are three key issues loss of
employment land sustainability and
visual impact
for employment land there is a
significant deficit of employment
planned in bidford and the district
the application applicant says they have
marketed the site unsuccessfully and our
own report supports them
i would draw your attention to a number
of fundamental flaws in our experts
desktop review
they use 2011 census figures to support
the predicted market size taking no
account of growth
and the surrounding catchment areas for
retail for sulphur priors welford me
unveil and lma that would naturally
gravitate to a biddeford location
the expert acknowledges that the retail
site
the site has not been marketed to the
principal retail sites and portals nor
to retailers
direct and it also makes unsubstantiated
abstractions about retailers appetite
for this location
i met with aldi on the 1st of may 2019
who indicated that for the right site
right price the site would be
appropriate for their
needs notwithstanding their desire now
coming forward to build in
ulster bidford is the next logical
location because their model is founded
on local stores being four to six miles
apart
the loss of the employment land far
outweighs the benefit of 55 additional
houses affordable houses meet district
need
noting our current delivery is 271
ahead of our housing delivery test
target we are on course to build in
excess of 16 000 homes against the
anticipated fourteen six in the core
strategy
and have a five-year land supply of six
point five one years
members should refer to pages seven and
eight of the report which talk about the
balance of arguments to retain
employment land this is a direct copy
of an extract of an email sent by john
carefort on the 3rd of march 2020
who is so concerned about the impact of
this proposal on the sustainability of
biddeford
that but notwithstanding the housing
enabling officers comments
he took the unusual step of emailing the
case officer to raise concerns
and flag the real very real balance of
harm benefit needing consideration
in terms of sustainability this will be
an entirely car dependent development
walking services to loca walking
distance to local services in bidford
range from 800 meters to 2 kilometers
far in excess of the 400 meter standard
our planning offices usually apply
and way more than the guidance on foot
journeys recommends
the site addresses district-wide needs
occupiers will have employment leisure
and family ties across the whole
district that can only be served by the
car
there is a significant visual impact the
entire site has levels significant
significantly higher above the street
level than the 300 millimeters usually
acceptable
for example plot 41 will be about a half
meter above street level
we then have to add in the three meter
high fence required by our eho
to create a berlin wall along wellington
road visible from waterloo road
mating an entirely unacceptable and as
one officer commented austere street
scene
you're entitled to weigh the visual harm
against the benefits of the application
site in order to refuse permission you
need robust reasons for refusal
i have set out nine reasons in your
update sheet this is a judgment of
weighing the planning balance between
the harm caused against the benefit of
additional housing
you can legitimately take an alternative
and justifiable view
different to that of your officers i
urge you to do so and refuse this
application
and give the ward members the parish
council and your officers to have the
opportunity to have meaningful
discussions
to bring forward a new employment and
retail scheme
on this site thank you members i will
happily take any questions
council planning thank you very much
well within your time limit um
so do we have any counselor parry
straight in there council barry
go ahead good evening and good evening
councillor pemberton
um obviously picking up on your points
on sustainability could you just advise
what the current status is with public
transport
from biddeford to stratford-on-avon and
other
nearby rural centres
thank you councillor parry there is a
bus service
service from the high street which is uh
something between 850 and 900 meters
from the application
site that provides uh some services
uh in the early morning uh then moving
to a one-hour service
and i think the last service is circa
6 45 7 o'clock um
it is uh it is unsuitable for anybody
uh working other than in
stratford-upon-avon uh working anything
other than a nine to five
job
thank you very much council pam members
do we have any other questions for
council hamilton
i'm seeing some shaking of heads so i'm
going to assume that is a nice council
of hampton thank you very much for that
um
feel free to stay on and watch uh the
rest of the descriptions
if you kind of mute your microphone
while you do that that would be greatly
appreciated
um okay so this time we are going to go
to our officer for technical questions
does anyone have any questions for our
officer
thanks for adam
thank you chairman um it was just going
through the report i couldn't
see a specific area that focused on
covet 19 impacts um i know that other
recent applications have uh included
that
um i might be missing it but i just want
to see if that was considered because i
know it is considered a material
planning
uh
um if you refer to um
unfortunately i haven't got page numbers
uh the penultimate i think it is
a page of the report and a time limit
it there is a reference to the covert 19
and also
condition one attaches an additional six
months
onto the standard three-year time limit
however i do
have to note that the applicants if
permission were to be granted
say that they probably wouldn't need
that because they're keen to get going
as soon as possible
thank you very much louise that's page
17 top of 17 and the conditions on page
18 of our gender pack for anyone that
needs to have a lick
um counselor dixon you have a question
uh thank you chairman um louise um
can we have the street scene again
please from wellington road
if this is the road to have a
three meter high fence upon it i didn't
see
that being depicted on the visualization
of the street scene
uh that was projected where's defense
counselor dixon if you if you refer to
this this elevation here
um the so these fake oh sorry sorry i
knocked it there um these these walls
sorry
the combination there's a wall here
that's it's
um it concertina's back and then this is
back of
um car parking bay so these are set back
i'll refer you again to let me just
quickly go up
so if you can see obviously there's
there's a wall here it's
set back then it's the backs of these
car parking spaces here that need to be
three meters in height so it's not along
the
wellington road it's along the back
gardens it's
it is on the wellington road street
scene to clarify
um and i think
in reference to the first plot yes there
is going to be a wall here
um at concertina's round going to the
back of pavement and but that will be
um it will be approximately i think 3.7
meters in overall height because of the
floor level difference
thank you chairman if i may follow up
with a another question
um the marketing
exercise obviously we have a slight
disagreement i believe between our
uh representatives here as to what the
marketing price may
have been but my question really is when
land is identified as brownfield
and we identify brownfield as being
suitable for housing within a built-up
area boundary
how do we prevent an owner only sticking
out for residential property values
of three through you chair um i mean
amazon young
report deals specifically with the value
of the site and and in terms of
assessment i mean obviously they are the
surveyors they deal with
land values um for both commercial and
residential
um and and retail as well um
and they considered um the
price acceptable for a site of the size
configuration
and situation um in terms of property
agents
um whatever they say but basically yes
they say that it is um an appropriate
use it's not over
inflated uh for for the commercial
proposals as
as originally marketed or indeed retail
thank you very much louise thank you
council dixon and councillor parry you
have a question
thank you chair um yes it's a it's a
connection
it's a question in connection with the
um community in
infrastructure levy obviously if this
was an open market um
development it would attract a a sill
contribution according to the to the
report of
just over 565 000 pounds
but obviously being um a fully
affordable
uh development the applicant can apply
for an exemption
which basically means there is utterly
no benefit
to bidford parish council which having
gone and got an ndp
would under normal circumstances be
the recipient of 000 pounds
to create further infrastructure
projects
for the parish i just my question
to the officers is um really picking up
on my question
to the applicant when i raised the
um query about the the need and the
demand
for shared ownership properties bearing
in mind there's been a shared ownership
property in bidford that's been
up for grabs for over 12 months that if
the applicant suddenly decided to change
the tenure of for example the shared
ownership properties
to private dwellings would
would those private dwellings um then
be sell compliant or
um could if if the committee were minded
to approve this application could there
be a condition applied
that at least if the tenure changed on
the site
then they would be still compliant
mr chairman i can probably answer this
in terms of the sale
um
somehow your your microphone muted there
um richard i'm not quite sure what
happened
can you hear me now we can yes please
please
uh yeah just to respond on the sill
point
um as you say they would nor ordinarily
have to pay
uh 565 000 pounds of sill
um there is a strong likelihood that
they will be exempt
through so regulations they still have
to make that application to us
for the exemption but affordable housing
is eligible
there are caveats within the sil regs
that if you apply and get an exemption
there are clawbacks that you then have
to honour that for a certain period
um sales builds are another example of
that i can't say for sure exactly what
the clawback is
but um there are lots of caveats in
there that prevent them doing one thing
one day and then
turning around the next day and getting
away with it
um it would be too easy for people to do
so there are safeguards in there for
that sort of thing
so ultimately we are covered in case
there is a change
yeah we're covered by the still rex
lovely
thank you very much um i have a quick
question if i may louise um councilor
pemberton alluded to
correspondence between yourself and uh
john carefort
i can't see any reference to that within
the
consultation element of the report
um i wonder if you could give us an idea
of what was said
and what consideration you gave to what
was said please um
yes chair um we don't ordinarily put
policy
comments within the report itself is in
terms of the consulti
um however i can confirm that um
as councillor pemberton did allude to um
in particular
with um
i think apologies i'm gonna have to
count pages it's the
it's the uh principle of development
section bottom part
of the report um it's the last paragraph
there about the technical
evidence um to inform the core uh
strategy plan making um
um sorry the council commissioned
um consultants to undertake the
employment land
marketing signal study for coventry and
warwickshire
so yes that that did come from um um
advice from john kefir to update us in
terms of
um uh yeah basically to update us with
respect to
uh the current position with um
requirements for commercial development
within
the district itself um and
and obviously we certainly weren't we're
shying away from that and within the
report it's it's that it's there
and it identifies that yes there there
has been sort of demand for
uh um for uh
commercial uses um but i i would then
refer you back to the
um bottom part penultimate bottom
paragraph of the report
um which it yes there is
clearly a demand for smaller startup
employment
um properties but again
it's it's caveatted with this site has
been
vacant for 10 years it has been marketed
for uh and it has been independently
assessed by
uh consultants who have analyzed its
price
it's uh the marketing evidence
and uh concluded that it's um
that it's undergone a reasonable extent
of marketing before coming forward and
therefore
with any type of development site um
the the the balance there is either the
loss of employment and the gain of a
of an affordable housing site which
obviously again is explored within
the rest of the report that there's a
significant
uh demand for affordable housing within
the district with it within the wider
district itself so it's
it that approach report is clear in
terms of uh weighing up that balance
okay so so in short yes uh you have had
correspondence you have considered it
and the evidence that provided by
the independent uh group
um uh has brought you to the conclusion
that that you've come to is
in a nutshell okay lovely thank you
um i don't see any other indication of
questions for officers
um unless anyone has a pressing question
they want to ask we will move into
debate
who would like to start on the debate
i can see councillor parry typing i'm
going to assume that says speak so i
will ask councillor paris to come in
straight away
thank you chair well i guess somebody
has to start first
um this is clearly a very finely
balanced
application um and i actually did a bit
of
homework on the previous um planning
application to see what level of support
there was
for the original retail
application several years ago and it was
interested to see
that actually both the parish council
and the ward member at that time
were in support of retail so they're not
just saying
they're not just paying lip service to
this because they don't
you know they would prefer to see that
um it was interesting to see that that
that was the case
um i also think you know um
in terms of a neighborhood development
plan um
we've got sways of communities spending
serious amounts of time pulling together
neighborhood development plans
and this was clearly highlighted
um by councillor fleming a number of
years that were the neighborhood
neighborhood development plan was pulled
together significant research will have
been
produced and then the residents were
supporting
94 percent um the referendum attracted a
yes vote
which um based on the number of
neighborhood development plans around
the district that's a very
high percentage so we clearly have a
situation
where residents are very keen to have
um this this brown field a piece of land
not be lost because of the economic
benefits
said against that we also have a
situation
if we look at our own core strategy
policies
we have the cs18 affordable housing
policy
which um basically is very keen that we
have
affordable housing pepper potted in
um residential developments and here we
have the application before us this
evening
where it's very very concentrated 50
affordable homes um and i have a big
problem with that
i would rather if if it was a housing
development that had come forward to us
this evening i would much rather have
seen an
integrated um community but this is
yes the agent talked about the
the various tenures within affordable
housing but at the end of the day it is
an affordable housing development where
there is no need
um bidford have carried out a housing
needs survey
it was highlighted this this evening in
one of the
um presentations that they've already
had 125
housing so anyone who's living here is
going to have to be coming
it's not actually coming from the
existing community
i also have a um as i say a problem cs19
talks about
housing mix we don't have this um
mix of the right sort of properties for
an actual development that's very
it's it's not a cohesive it's not going
to promote a cohesive community
we also have a situation um and
additional planning reasons
um i think this development would have a
great effect
on the character of the neighborhood um
because of the
the barriers and the walls that have got
to be put up
um behind waterloo road
so i really feel that this this
particular development in isolation
is totally out of character
from the existing development within the
vicinity
we also have a situation um on the
um which was highlighted
by cs 22 which is the
loss of employment land and really it's
the cumulative
impact of all these reasons um
that i feel i just cannot go with the
officer's recommendation on this we have
so many reasons we not just got one it's
a cumulative
impact and i'm also concerned that
particularly you know the impact on
bidford parish council
um there's no sill money coming to them
um
there's just no benefit at all and i
just don't think it sits it's not
sustainable
we have a very poor public transport
system
um and i really i i've given a load of
reasons i therefore
will be going against the officers
recommendation and i propose
that we refuse this application on those
grounds thank you
thank you very much councillor parry
councillor ed and you have vindicated
you'd like to speak
thank you chair um yeah a lot of what um
councillor paris just said uh rings very
true with my mind as well and
the loss of a potential um
industrial or commercial site
where clearly by the looks of it their
ndp
in econ 1 and econ 2 as pointed out by
council of pemberton
um it goes against that i think we'd be
hamstringing the community i think
there's a lot of
feeling in bidford uh that they've
had their share of housing development
and i think i'll
i see that others have seconded uh
councillor paris um
recommendation to refuse uh i will say i
can do it verbally but you know i'm
happy to let the others go with that
thank you councillor and given you our
first to speak in your first your first
to formally
second uh we will we'll take your second
um counselor adam obviously you have
indicated in the chat that you would
like to second
um would you like to speak um at this
point
hey chairman i think everything i was
going to say has been very well said by
uh
the two council before me so thank you
lovely thank you and cancer dixon i can
see you seconded as well would you like
to speak at this point
nothing to uh chairman thank you okay
lovely
so let me just um i'll try and sum up um
the reasons for refusal uh that council
parry has put and has been seconded by
councillor ed and
council parry uh once i've gone through
all this if you just confirm or tell me
if i've got it completely wrong
um so i believe you were talking about
the um the mix of housing which i
understand falls under
uh cs18 uh you were talking about
the character of the area and the
negative impact it would have on the
street scene
uh i believe that falls under cs 9 and
as10
um you also talked about the loss of
employment land
under cs 22 and
as those individually but not just as
individuals the cumulative effect of all
three of those
are your reasons for refusal is that a
fair summation of what you've said
yeah i'd also like to add cs18 because
it talks about affordable housing should
be
um not in clusters it needs to be
more spread out and here we have a
concentrated cluster
of 40 of 50 affordable homes
all together in a central point which
doesn't lead to
a cohesive community
okay nicely put i do have cs 18 written
down but i think you've experienced that
a lot
but a lot better than i could have done
so thank you the just i i just want to
put members um
uh get their thoughts on or see if this
changes your thoughts
on cs22 lost employment land clearly we
have had an independent
um uh review of the marketing
and whether or not it would or wouldn't
be appropriate to go towards housing
given we've got that and that's the
evidence that's presented in front of us
um are you still happy that we put that
in as an additional
um uh reason for refusal or include it
in the cumulative effect of
how do you want to do that council barry
i i personally feel it is part of the
cumulative
impact but it also needs to be linked to
the weight
that we need to be giving to the bidford
um
neighborhood development plan
okay lovely um i can see council edin
has agreed uh councillor dixon
you've written audition in the um in the
meeting chat i'm assuming you want to
add
uh a reason for refusal uh it was merely
that and hasn't mentioned
the uh ndp and i think we should
therefore include econ 1 and econ 2 of
the bidford plan
as part of the uh reasons for refusal
okay um council parry did mention it in
her
very final point so
thank you um louise do you have all of
that
uh in front of you now are you happy
with the reason well not happy but do
you have sufficient reasons
um in front of you to form uh a decision
notice
should members go along that line thank
you through your chair
apologies um my children at a vital
moment just
ran into the place so i do apologize for
that
um basically we've got um um
i've got three reasons in particular
there's so it's
um the mix of houses and the
concentrated cluster of affordable
dwellings failing to provide a
cohesive uh community so we're referring
now to
policy cs18 as councilor perry is
referring to
the harm to the character of the street
scene um
now is that in particular because of the
um
the the uh
the acoustic walls and and um fencing is
in is that i believe that was the case
but i'll ask
councillor harry to speak on that well i
actually think it's
i'm not sure quite what sorry
um because of that the actual proposed
development is out of character with the
existing development in the vicinity
which again is a planning reason
so because of the walls and yeah yeah
and
i mean the the the the proposed
development is out of character with the
existing development links into both
cs18 and cs19
okay but is but is a material planning
reason
i believe okay um
just to pick up on the character point
which particular aspect of character
you're talking about the pattern of
development
the design the materials we've obviously
got the fence and the bricks of the
walls along wellington road are there
any other particular areas of concern
no but it but but my area of concern
falls back again onto cs18 and cs19 with
the mix of
the mix of tenure and the fact that
affordable homes
the affordable housing shouldn't be done
in in
um concentrated clusters it should be
like any other development
is is is pepper potted and here we have
it to be honest with you richard if it
was just a small development
of seven to ten it there wouldn't be a
problem but because it's 50
it's a large number to put concentrated
affordable
homes in one area there
but i think it's it's the cumulative
impact when you consider
all the aspects so it's not one
particular thing it's the cumulative
impact of all those reasons that we've
identified
if i could just advise here each refusal
reason has to stand on its own
uh which is why i'm trying to distill
down here we
we've already got the one about the
cohesion and the clustering effect
that is a if you like a social matter
but the one i'm asking about is the
visual one the design matter
in terms of how it affects the
settlement pattern the character of the
area
are there any particular areas other
than that impact on wellington road
no it's the it's
okay and then then i think we've got
as i understand it a third reason around
the loss of the employment use
and that's where the ndp policies uh
econ 1 and econ 2 come in
and also cs cs22 cs22 the core strategy
of course yeah
um and effective we've had expert advice
on that but members aren't convinced
with that we
what i would say is we don't have any
country advice from any experts on that
uh so we're in we're in a weak position
if we went to appeal on that because we
don't have any evidence the contrary
i think the weight needs to be given
then to the neighborhood development
plan on econ 1 and econ 2.
okay well then the neighborhood
development plan says similar to cs22 in
that there needs to be evidence
in order to lose that employment use
if i'm if i may jump in here please um
it has been uh put to members by
uh councillor fleming that um a
neighbouring
business did want to seek to expand on
that site
that is evidence to say that there is an
appetite there is a desire
uh and therefore is evidence against the
report that has been produced
okay well i i've not seen that evidence
i'm not disputing that but at the moment
that's conjecture so
members just need to be aware of that
understood
okay so um i think we've i i think we've
developed the uh the reasons for refusal
quite nicely i think they're pretty
concise and we can we can draw up the
the wording for them precisely after the
this meeting um given we have got
proposal
and it has been seconded to refuse on
those grounds um i think we should take
a roll call now and a vote
um on uh whether we go with the proposal
or against it
so members um i will start but uh when
you're called in if you could say your
name and whether you're
for against or abstaining from the uh
from the proposal uh that would be great
so councillor richards
four thank you chairman councillor adam
councillor adam for refusal
thank you councillor dixon
for refusal councillor dixon for refusal
thank you councillor councillor eden
that's reading for councillor fitter
councillor fitter for the refusal and
councillor parry
uh councillor parry for the refusal
thank you that's unanimous chairman
thank you thank you very much liz so
uh committee therefore resolves to
refuse application 1900
701 f2l for the reasons given
members thank you very much for that um
we will take a very short
one minute uh interval while we bring in
the speakers for our next item
um so if you could mute your microphones
for a moment and we will
go into that brief moment of pause
okay uh we will reconvene our meeting
now we have all of our speakers good to
go so
uh we are moving on to application
twenty zero zero five
two two very that land off stockton
road in longington our presenting
officer is eddie wrench eddie over to
you
thank you chair i'll just get up the
presentation now
okay that should be on now we can see it
thank you
thank you thank you chair this is a
an application to vary of condition one
of planning approval 17
forward slash 01211 rem
and the the proposed amendment is to
allow for elevational and floor plan
changes to house type g
which covers plot 5153 and 65 to 66
it is partially retrospective
um the site as can be is denoted here by
the black dot
is on the eastern edge of long
itchington to the south of the stockton
road and to the north of the canal
uh this plan is the approved site layout
for the
site which is currently being built out
the blue highlighted plots denotes the
uh the different the property type which
is type g which is proposed to be
amended
here on the left you can see the
proposed
elevations and floor plans for the
property with the approved elevations
and floor plans on the right hand side
the actual footprint of the dwelling is
unchanged as is its location
also the height of the main ridge
is the same the main external uh
alteration is that the front gable end
ridge height
and ease as can be seen on the top
left-hand side of the slide
uh would be it would be well is increa
has been increased
with a window inserted to that elevation
there is also some
uh small changes to roof lights to the
front and the back
internally the layout has uh changed uh
quite a bit
certainly from the raising of the roof
light to the gable end
uh has allowed for an additional bedroom
upstairs
where there was one before and there's
also the introduction of a downstairs
study as well
finally as it's the retrospective nature
of the application
these are the two of the property types
that
front onto stockton road which have
actually been built
just to provide some context
okay updates include some corrections
within the report
and additional details regarding sill
chairman the recommendation is to grant
subjects the conditions on page 27 of
the agenda
thank you
wonderful thank you very much eddie we
will move straight to
our first speaker who i believe is
counselor atkinson
from long itchington parish council
council atkinson are you able to hear us
you may need to press star 6 to unmute
yourself
um can you hear me we can indeed
fantastic good to hear from you yes so
you have three minutes we'll give you a
30 second warning before your time is up
and whenever you're ready please begin
good evening um i'm barbara atkins chair
of long ishington parish council
initially we wish to assert about the
unfairness of retrospective applications
in general
and this one as a breach of planning
rules and a breach of trust
we're not so naive as to think a lengthy
and expensive appeal
process will ensue but we felt we had a
duty to our community to be heard in
public at this meeting
indeed it is very difficult when a
couple of the dwellings i believe
are already inhabited this situation
only arose because the parish council
asked a question regarding the houses
being built at keepers meadow
if we had not then the breaches would
never have been discovered
stratfor district council have some
responsibility for this having not
carried out any building control
even though the year-long battle to
achieve an acceptable housing mix at the
reserve matters stage
should have been a clear warning sign
that monitoring might be needed
sales hoardings for example advertising
three and four bedroom dwellings when we
thought we had agreed
to two three and four bedroom dwellings
on the site
the changes we discussed here today in
effect
are four-bedroomed accommodation where
only three bedrooms were permitted
these five particular dwellings are
being marketed as four bedroom whatever
might be said here today
changing a three-bedroom dorm of
bungalow where most of the accommodation
is on the ground floor
to a dwelling where the accommodation is
more evenly shared on ground and first
floor
means that people needing mainly ground
floor living are excluded
four bedroom properties also attract a
premium
outline permission in 2016 didn't give
any detail to the housing mix
in 2017 the reserved matters were
negotiated with the hard work of eddie
wrench for almost a year
and eventually the community felt it
would receive the mix which we need and
which
two different independent analyses
supported
highlighting bungalows much needed by
older or disabled residents
as well as two-bedroom accommodations
what was agreed at the reserve matters
stage appears not to have been binding
thus giving an opportunity to manipulate
the process
we have a system where no housing detail
is given at the outline
stage when agreements are unalterable
but the important details are agreed
later in a process which clearly has
little teeth
we've been told that the principle upon
which the planning process is built
is one which places the risk on the
builder rather than the power on the
enforcer
mr chairman we would argue that it pays
for a developer to take these risks and
the people who suffer are those living
in the communities where such building
takes place
thank you councillor atkinson thank you
very much for that well within your time
as well so i appreciate that
members do you have any questions for
councillor atkinson
i'll give you a couple of seconds to
write in the chat
looks like a no so counselor arkansas
thank you very much for your
contribution
um we will move on to our next speaker
in that case
so our next thank you our next speaker
um is rachel claire from barrett's david
wilson homes rachel are you
there can you hear us you may need to
press star 6 to unmute
rachel are you able to hear us
uh i can hear you now fabulous we can
hear you as well
so um same rules apply three minutes we
will give you a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready please do go ahead
okay uh thank you chair
um good evening committee members and
officers uh thank you for holding this
virtual meeting this evening
and the case officer eddie wrench for
working proactively
with us such this application could be
presented for consideration
at this evening's committee meeting the
application seeks retrospective approval
for changes to the floor plans and
elevations of house type g
comprising of five plots on the
development
notwithstanding these changes the
proposals do not alter the siting
the type or the mix of the dwellings
which are being considered as part of
this application
there are five of the house types on on
the site this
uh these locations are highlighted in
yellow on the site
layout shown on the screen plots 51
52 and 53 are within the heart of the
development
both spots 65 and 66 are on the stockton
road frontage
behind the mature retained hedgerow
which is over two meters in height
the rationale behind the changes was
purely to respond to customer feedback
and to assist with the saleability of
the unit
the overall number of rooms within the
dwellings remain as approved at eight
on the ground floor the changes being
the creation of a hallway
from which the ground floor rooms except
for the kitchen can be directly accessed
off
the provision of a study which provides
a flexible space for a number of
potential uses
including home working the stairs have
therefore been
relocated to where the family bathroom
was
and bedroom two has been split to
accommodate the family bathroom and
study
the first floor now accommodates
bedrooms two and three
and a shower room the amendments
facilitate
the provision of three good-sized
bedrooms whereas the approved plans
delivered a disproportionately large
bedroom on the first floor
representing an inefficient use of the
space available
we believe the changes to the internal
configuration
significantly improve the accommodation
on offer to the future occupiers
whilst continuing to provide five
three-bedroom
dormer bungalows as the approved plans
also do
the main change to the external
elevation of the dwelling
is the front gable projection which has
been marginally increased in height
by 0.475 of a meter
this to allow sufficient headroom to
accommodate the proposed second bedroom
the dwelling's overall ridge height has
not been increased
we firmly believe changes to the
elevation of the dwellings
create a more attractive property
externally which enhances our streets
stockton road and successfully
terminates the view at the head of the
united state road for plot 51.
to conclude we believe the changes to
health poke g provide for dwellings that
are more attractive and with better
living accommodation
whilst retaining all five as three bed
dormer bungalows
to ensure the mix and type across the
site is consistent with that approved at
the reserve matters stage
and we hope that you are therefore able
to consider this application favorably
and follow your case officer's
recommendation to grant permission
for the amended plan to household you uh
thank you again
to address this committed tonight and
i'll gladly answer any queries that you
have
lovely thank you very much uh councillor
parry you've indicated you had a
question
thank you chairman uh yes to the
um to david wilson holmes um
obviously david wilson homes which is
part of barrett you're one of the
if not the largest um house builder in
the
uk can you explain why you have not
built the development in accordance with
planning permission
and would you not agree what sort of
message this sends out
to local communities um
you know i'm just interested to hear
what you have to say because obviously
you've got
you have your own building control you
have your own planning people
i'd like to know how the uk's largest
house builder
has gone ahead and built some homes
that do not conform to approve planning
commission
thank you so we we do acknowledge that
this uh hasn't been
done correctly and uh we can only
apologize
for that uh we saw an opportunity
to improve the accommodation of the
units on offer
whilst retaining the same footprint and
bedroom numbers
of the original dwellings um it was just
genuine human error
that the decision for the changes to be
made has fallen
between the gap of our previous planning
manager having left
and me taking on the role um
and clearly we just say that the
delivery of both the spiny fields
development across the road
of stockton road and at keepers meadow
we've
strived to establish a trusting
relationship with the people of
longington
with the quality of built form and the
sense of place that's already been
created
hopefully speaking for itself in this
regard
we do acknowledge this isn't the correct
way however you know we are here to try
and amend the situation
in accordance uh with what is required
okay thank you i was going to ask much
the same question as well counselor
parry
members do we have any other questions
for rachel claire
i don't see anything popping up and i'm
seeing some shaking heads so i'm gonna
assume that's a no
uh rachel thank you very much for your
contribution um
please do feel free to stay on uh or or
continue watching on the online portal
uh we will now move then to thank you we
will now move to our next speaker
who is counselor adam councillor adam
whenever you're ready you know the drill
five minutes 30 second warning
over to you thanks very much
the variation is quite clearly
attempting to subvert the requirements
of the original planning commission
by including a study at ground floor
level
increasing the number of rooms available
for users bedrooms without being upfront
or transparent about this
to the pope planning planning process
the officer notes that this could indeed
be used as a bedroom
but it is being it being on the ground
floor offers more
flexibility to this interpretation
however
the description of these houses is still
dormer bungalows
housing that specif specifically offers
ground floor bedrooms as part and parcel
of the general layout
therefore flexibility is not appropriate
in this case
the reality is that the room is being
designated as a fourth bedroom
as is currently being advertised by the
applicant
if this were then considered to be a
study these should not be advertised as
dormant bungalows at all
much less for four-bedroom dormer
bungalows
having a majority of the bedrooms at
first floor level and this type of
variation would therefore be subject to
a full
application and the scrutiny this is
subjective
either way the housing mix is being
changed by this application
and is subject to planning policy cs19
which i believe
it fails to meet regarding the process
by which we reached this application
the officer's report for the original
application highlighted the
development of the proposed housing mix
are
originally being heavily skewed towards
three and four plus bedroom dwellings
was well outside the preferred mix range
tabulated under policy cs19
the housing mix was therefore a
pertinent condition of the original
permission granted to correct this the
outline planning permission did not give
any detail
of the housing mix and so this was
agreed to be set out a reserve matters
stage
this was followed by lengthy discussion
with the parish council
into which the african entered it was
believed at the time
in good faith agreeing to engage in the
process
at this stage represents a willingness
to abide by these conditions
this application now flies in the face
of this and disrespects the community
and the planning authority itself
a housing needs survey was completed on
behalf of the parish council in 2016
when preparing the neighborhood plan as
such the reserve matters were argued
over
um in order to provide the community
with the mix that was agreed on by two
different independent
independent analyses specifically
highlighting bungalows as a required
housing type
the parish council ultimately withdrew
objection to the original application
specifically on the basis that the
developer amended the housing mix to
better suit the local housing need as
noted therefore the original application
was made
and accepted on the basis of an agreed
housing mix being at the heart of the
permission
this application has been submitted
under section 73 of the town of country
planning act
i believe the assessment by the officer
of this being appropriate can be
interpreted a different way within our
planning
framework and suggest that this
application does not
seek to sorry that this application does
seek to fundamentally alter
what was originally granted in going
against the needs of the community
as verified by independent reports
therefore is you know inappropriate that
this application
is being submitted under section 73 and
a new planning application is required
for these proposals
which would afford stratfor district
council as a local planning authority
and the statutory council tease the due
scrutiny
this development solely requires the
decision made on this application will
become a precedent for the future
and the weight of this must be
considered as part of the decision
regardless of the suggestion that the
rest of the site is planned to be
completed as approved
the ongoing enforcement actions for the
site
as a whole give rise to concerns of
serious implications for the future of
the community
this is therefore material in this case
i urge the committee to refuse this
application
council adam thank you very much for
that um before councillor parry gets her
typing in i'm going to ask you a quick
question you
you talked about section 73 uh being an
inappropriate way in which to determine
this application or submit this
um that it should have been submitted as
a full i'm not sure i fully understood
what you were trying to say could you
please
uh give me a a brief synopsis of what
that meant
yes certainly um based on the officer's
report
uh essentially i'll get it up in front
of me
the the way in which that that covers it
is um
is based on whether the the changes at
the heart of the
um the sorry i've got the wording in
front of me here
um i think i think goes to the heart of
the decision that was made
to the heart of the original decision
and whether that was the thing being
altered
um by the variation i believe in this
case that because the
housing mix was so crucial to the parish
council were
removing their objection um that that
mix
is at the heart of that original
application and the permission
and that therefore any variation to that
which i believe this is seeking to do in
changing the mix
makes it um requirement for a full
application instead
and i think that that's just the the
interpretation that i think we could
could take within our planning framework
okay that is that is understood and
clear thank you very much council parry
thank you chair um council adam can you
can do you know how many more units are
yet to be
built that haven't that haven't been in
in terms of the overall
scheme i i don't have an exact number i
do go up there fairly regularly to see
and there's still what looked like
around a third of it was still
under construction uh the last time i
checked
um like i said i didn't do an actual
count at the time
um and so if that may be able to come
confirmed by somebody else
but there is still a between let's say a
quarter and a third of it was the last
what it looked like from my viewing list
so there is scope
there is not all of it has been built
out as
you know it's which is hence the reason
why you're suggesting coming back for a
full planning application
again yeah and i think that would
essentially offer
the control mechanism that the planning
authority is
um deserves in this so that it could be
properly scrutinized
and make sure that the full site is
developed
in a way in accordance with our original
decision and
the way in which suits are are planning
policies
thank you okay thank you both um
uh members i don't see any other
questions i'm gonna give you a couple of
seconds if anyone wants to write
anything and say they want to ask a
question
i'm going to take that as a no so uh
council adam thank you
very much you will of course be staying
on because you'll be joining us for our
next two items
um okay so in that case let's move to
uh questions to our officers um any
points of clarification
um eddie i'm going to start if i may uh
the point about the
section 73 versus full application could
you give us your view of
why it's appropriate to do under 73 and
not through a full
yes chair thanks um it's an interesting
interesting one it wasn't what i
prepared for but
in terms of when you're talking about
going to the heart of the permission
you're really looking at are they
altering
significantly moving away from what was
originally planned for the site
um so there was obviously an outline
permission for the 81
dwellings on the site this variation and
the subsequent
um reserve matters part of that it
hasn't moved away from that
and i think you know as there was no
mix on the original outline permission
and it's purely looking at the principle
of the site and and the numbers and what
and what was proposed i still think it
comes within the parameters of what was
originally agreed out that outline
and the subsequent um reserve matters so
i think
i think when you're talking about where
things go to the heart it's where it
it's fundamentally changing that
permission in a way
and in this case i don't think it's to
such a degree
you know that wouldn't it would move it
outside the section 73
to a full application really if they're
adding new properties or significantly
changing some element there's more of a
case to be made where
where where it could be moving away but
as i said in this case
um officers consideration there it is uh
a
minor material change in this case so
that's why we've accepted it and taken
on it
this way okay so just following on from
that if i may the um
in terms of percentages of the uh
housing mix
clearly we're adding an extra what two
bedrooms
one per dwelling how does it change the
housing mix that was originally agreed
in percentage terms
well in offices opinion um
they we they were approved as three
bedrooms
and in the report we've stated that we
still consider them to
be three bedrooms i think the point of
contention is obviously the study
and we've taken the view that a ground
floor
study where it's positioned within the
house
it's it's more of a gray area where we
wouldn't necessarily consider it fully
one way or the other but on balance we
feel that
you know it could certainly be used as a
study particularly in the circumstances
now where
you know we have a significant amount of
population working from home
there's a you know there's a good chance
of it so it's not to be that it's 100
going i
i appreciate that what they're marketing
it for is one thing
um and that's what's um upset the parish
council to certain degree
but i think on balance officers have
taken the view that there is no change
in
in the mix obviously it you know if
members felt that that was a four bed
then there would obviously be a shift
from three bed to four bed properties
which would
move it further away from you know what
our preferred mix would be set out
i can show you the approved mix if that
helps of what was on the site just to
get some bearings
oh yeah i don't think it would cause any
harm yeah
so yeah this table shows the approved
mix um that was uh approved on the site
layout for the reserve matters site
okay that's helpful
all right lovely thank you very much
eddie um i also have councillor dixon
would like to ask you a question so
council dixon when you're ready
thank you chairman uh eddie can we uh
see the floor plans please
i'm particularly interested in noting i
think this might be a bit of a
discussion as to whether these are
bungalows or houses
um and a floor plan hopefully
will assist me
i'm looking to see where the bathroom is
on the ground floor
uh for the proposed for the approved and
the proposed
okay has it has it moved has it changed
room the main bathroom on the approved
was here i
think can you see that um red highlight
we can see the red highlight point eddie
would you mind zooming out a little bit
on that
um screen at the moment i've only got
half of the approved
uh on my screen it's the same for all
members
i can zoom into that i can get the floor
plan
open on itself if that will help that
would be fine
thank you
then i'll be able to zoom in a bit more
so that's the screen
so this is the approved layout
so we had the
bathroom on the ground floor was
the main bathroom and then there was a
shower room on the first floor
um yeah
and the bathroom has shifted to the back
elevation of the property on the ground
floor
and there remains a shower room on there
on the um first floor
so it's lifted it's the bathroom on the
ground floor shifted slightly because of
the change in the um
staircase but it is the main bathroom is
still located on the ground floor
thank you very much eddie no problem
terry
thank you um councillor parry you've got
a question
yeah it's just really some clarification
um
because obviously we have a we have a
situation where we've got
um residents who've bought the property
and are currently living in it
um in terms if is if we were minded to
to support the officer's recommendation
is there any
any way conditions could be applied to
any of the other plots of the site that
were able then to revert
revert back to you know
that they could could be in the same
that um
the approved unit i'm probably not
making myself very clear
i think are you talking about the
prospect of enforcement
for other people yeah i mean that's
obviously a separate matter for the
enforcement team and ultimately
regulatory committee so it's not
something that's in front of members
tonight
can i can i also ask in terms of
building control
what would our team of sdc
um have done in terms of
checking that the um the developers were
producing
what they had planning permission
for building control obviously go out
and check
the building regulations plans they
don't monitor uh planning permissions
because obviously they're under separate
acts
okay does that answer your questions
councillor perry yeah
okay lovely um thank you very much eddie
um
we will move then into uh the debate
would anyone like to
dive in and start
if not it's gonna fall to me i think um
i will get us underway in that case so
members of the committee and members of
the council generally know how much it
irritates me that uh we end up seeing
retrospective planning applications
there is clearly
a planning framework in place and once
one once a planning application has been
approved one should build out
uh in accordance with that planning
application um
an independent individual uh
could be excused for making a mistake
and i understand
that we have retrospective for that
purpose but a major
uh builder within the uk doing that
really really does frustrate me i find
it oh i think cancer adam made the point
it's just disrespectful
not only to the parish councils but also
to the planning authority and frankly
the law
uh within within which we operate
having said that we do have a
framework for retrospectives um and we
do need to consider
whether there is a material change to uh
and as we've pointed out that goes to
the heart of the original decision
um in terms of the building itself the
floor
floor plan remains the same uh we've
seen an increase of 0.7 meters on front
gable
um to my mind it actually looks better
with that
increase but i appreciate that is
subjective
um and within the internals once a
property has been sold and is in the
ownership of
um a private individual uh my
understanding is and
i'm sure our officers will will dive in
and tell me otherwise
my understanding is internal changes do
not need planning permission
so we're in a kind of a an interesting
situation where
it is frustrating it really i mean as i
say it really does irritate me when when
we have these things come forward
but we do have a framework that we have
to uh work within
um and i can see no planning reason why
we would refuse this
variation um i am open to a suggestion
from other members
but at this point i propose that we do
grant in line with the officer's
recommendation and details on the update
sheet
um counselor parry i can see you have
written you want to
to speak in a second so if you'd like to
go ahead
um very eloquently put mr chairman
um it's extremely frustrating
i have to say i i would like to commend
the parish council
and the ward member for making such good
presentations
to us um and i just hope they realize
that if we had the power
to refuse it for genuine planning
reasons
i think all of us probably well i can't
speak for any other members of the
committee
um that we were going to be going down
that route but unfortunately
um we don't have that option there are
not
material planning reasons that we can
refuse it um
and um i would just like to think that
the i would like to like to hope
that the builders actually make a proper
apology to the ward member and the
parish council
rather than just having paid lip service
to it tonight
because one asked that question but i
think they need to think very
carefully and very seriously about their
pr reputation
um because we have been forced into a
corner
um and that you know as the uk's largest
house builder um that would appear to be
more interested in building
shareholder value um than
than responding and and doing the thing
that they should do in following
planning permission
so it is i don't have any other
alternative but to second you mr
chairman i think you put all the
very valid reasons very poignantly but i
just hope the builders do
do the right thing and make a proper
apology
to the parish council and the ward
member because
we have no alternative in my view but to
support the officer's recommendation
thank you councillor parry i would add
to your list of people that require
apology the people who have bought the
homes that are subject to this
application the stresses that they must
be under
as a result of this beggar's belief
council dixon you've indicated that you
wanted a second it obviously already has
been seconded um would you like to speak
or shall we move straight to a vote
straight to the vote chairman good man
okay in that case we are voting on
granting the application in line with
the officer's recommendation and the
update sheet
um i will go first council richards four
thank you chairman councillor dixon
councillor dixon
four
and councillor parry councillor parry
four thank you that's three votes for
chairman with two abstentions wonderful
thank you liz so uh in that case
the committee um therefore uh grant
application
twenty zero zero five double to very
for the reasons given um we will take
another one minute interval
while we bring in our speakers for our
next item um if you could all mute your
microphones and we will be brought back
in shortly
hello
hello who do we have here uh christian
lawrence
christian hi welcome um we are just in
an adjourned
uh we're just adjourned for the moment
um if you could press star six
on your keypad that will mute you and i
will call you in at the point we would
like you to speak if that's okay
great just just to confirm um i'm
splitting my time with our highways
consultants if that's okay
that's absolutely fine we'll confirm all
that ready
thank you very much
okay
okay we now have all of our speakers
with us so we will continue our meeting
hello i can hear someone's voice
good evening to you this is adrian smith
from studly parish council
hello good evening to you um we are just
coming out in the germans while we were
bringing in all our speakers
um i will ask you if you wouldn't mind
muting your um
your phone i think star 6 should mute
you um and we will
hear from our officers as they introduce
and then i'll call for you
at the at the appropriate time for you
to speak okay
okay fabulous i think we're all muted so
uh members um we are now going to look
at application twenty zero zero
five six one f u l our presenting
officer is sarah mcpherson sarah
whenever you're ready thank you chair
let me just get the presentation
[Music]
up
uh okay
the application before members is for
the demolition of 15 lock-up garages
just off watts road in studly
and the erection of two dwellings this
slide shows the site
edged in red
this slide shows the proposed site plan
there will be two dormer bungalow style
dwellings with parking to the front
and gardens to the rear
this slide shows the proposed elevations
of the dwellings
including pitched roof dormers and porch
as you can see from the proposed floor
plans the dwellings would have two
bedrooms
and both dwellings would be the same
moving to site photos this picture shows
the entrance to the site and the access
drive
i've included a site plan in the corner
so you can see where the photos are
taken from
these photos are taken looking to the
left and right down the street with the
entrance
in front of me
this photo shows the inside of the site
looking back towards watts road to the
south
this photo is taken facing the north
western corner of the site
which backs onto the rear of dwellings
in allendale crescent
this photo faces the northeastern corner
of the site
and that's the end of my presentation
thank you
marvelous thank you very much sarah um
we will go straight into
our first speaker who is councillor
smith um
from the parish council councillor smith
you will need to press
star and then six in order to unmute
your phone
and we should be able to hear you then
so if you do that now that'd be great
just to reiterate that star and six will
unmute you
hello good evening council richards can
you hear me we can indeed well done
superb stuff um so you have you have
three minutes um i will give you a 30
second warning
uh sorry liz will give you a 30 second
warning
um before your time is up and whenever
you're ready feel free to begin
well good evening chair good evening
ladies and gentlemen and thank you for
the opportunity
to represent studly parish council on
this application
the parish council have objected once
and that we are now objecting again
and it's based on the following reasons
which have been um
correlated by their council for me to
present to you tonight
item number one is there are no
electrical
vehicle charging points which probably
comes under conditions of some sort
one of the key elements is the access
and aggress for the parking
for 33 roland avenue and 16 watts road
this will restrict the vehicle accident
access
for both of these properties
there is no facilities for visitor
parking
and there is a real possibility of
conflict between the two
new occupants and the residents of
number 33 and number 16.
we believe that the layout should be
reconsidered with the size of the
properties further reduced
to ensure there is no potential conflict
no facility is provided for the safe
location of the waste and recycling bins
at the entrance of the site
due to the confines of the site and the
distance from the highways
highway the bins will have to be left at
the curb side
restricting vehicle access and aggress
due to the size mass and bulk and what
is considered to be the bland elevations
with no features these properties will
have a negative impact
to the immunity of the residents of
homes that surround the site
there is lack of immunity space for the
proposed development
standby without careful attention to the
boundary treatments
residents of the existing homes will be
overlooked by the new properties
the site is presently accessed from
watts road with the houses either side
having mature hedges
these are but the footpath this means
that an acceptable visitor
visibility display cannot be achieved
without agreement with the properties
either side of the entrance
due to the length 32 meters and the
narrowness 2.5 meters of the drive
there is no possibilities of vehicles
passing each other
if one was entering or leaving the site
they would have conflict
also there is no laid out footpath for
the whole of the drive making it
impossible for a vehicle to safely pass
pedestrians using the driveway
due to the on-street parking along this
stretch of watts road
access to the site could at times be
difficult
there is no provision for a street light
along the entirety of the drive
making this unsafe for pedestrians again
in the dark
30 seconds
in short the access drive is
unacceptable for the two bungalows and
perhaps
a development of lesser ambition with
one bungalow
would be more appropriate i thank you
for your
your time and opportunity to reflect
these comments from the parish council
castle smith that's fantastic almost
dead on three minutes well done thank
you
um if you just bear with and i will ask
members if they have any questions
remember if you can indicate in the chat
that would be great okay standing by
uh i'm not seeing anything from members
for questions so
i think you've um you've managed to
cover all the points and and made them
very happy so
um thank you very much council smith um
we will move on to
our next speakers if you want to uh hang
out councillor smith and continue to
watch on the online portal that would
probably
be the best way to do it um our next
speakers then are christian lawrence
uh who is the agent and nigel venning
who i'm assuming is
um a uh transport consultant um as
alluded to earlier
um mr lawrence do you want to unmute
first with star six um
and we will hear from you first
let me know when you have been able to
do that please hello
hello so you you alluded to earlier
you're going to split your time i'm
assuming you want
a minute 30 for yourself and then a
minute 30 for nigel is that right
uh no um we will we both got um
something to read so so i'll stop um
after 30 seconds or so
and then it'll move on to nigel if
that's okay okay
uh that's fine in that case if nigel
wants to unmute his um his phone as well
with star six
um and then we can flow nicely between
the two of you if that's okay
seamless hopefully hopefully nigel are
you are you there
good evening welcome fantastic
everyone's here and able to speak
good okay so um christian if you want to
start as soon as you go down nigel if
you take over and
what we'll do is give you a 30 second
warning before um three minutes
is up so whenever you're ready fire away
thank you thank you chairman and
committee members uh for giving us the
opportunity to talk in support of our
application off what's road
the proposal seeks to demolish 15
existing garages for the replacement
with two
dormer bungalows it has been identified
that the neighborhood plan has a
specific need for two
bedroom bungalows the application before
you today has officer recommendation for
approval
with support from all statutory
consultees the proposals retain
access to two existing rear gardens with
the reduction in vehicular movements
given
the original garage used for the site
the properties comply with all required
separation distances to adjacent
boundaries and houses
whilst providing sustainable development
in an established residential area
paragraph 38 of national planning policy
framework
states that local planning authorities
should approach decisions on proposed
development in a positive and creative
way
development of underutilized land and
urban areas
which may attract vandalism and
anti-social behavior
should be encouraged development
promotes
promotes two door bombers and all the
members have referred to the likelihood
of
elderly or frail residents these
residents are likely to travel less
and not have two cars in normal
circumstances traffic may be no more
than 10 movements
in a whole weekday unless if the
residents are retired
therefore the risks associated with
multiple vehicles at the same time are
overstated
in practice the risks of cars meeting
each other
is negligible the safety concerns
associated with this quantity of traffic
cannot be construed to be severe
uh we refer to waste and we've got a
waste collection point halfway along the
access
road and that's simply a reasonable
position between walking distances for
residents
and the operatives collecting refuge and
recycling
the walking distances are entirely
reasonable considering the
guideline parameters in manifold streets
uh in our transport statement
on the planning upgrade for the planning
application we refer to the excellent
safety record on watts road and local
streets
minor concerns related to vehicles
emerging onto watts road
are addressed with traffic coming we're
putting road humps in just as vehicles
enter onto the footwear
to keep speeds very low and the risks
for pedestrians and road users are
negligible
street lighting hasn't been included
along the driveway but this could be
added as a planning condition
say low level bollard lighting 30
seconds
yes electric charging points can be
provided
the highway authorities concerned no
objection to planning application
their letter does not refer to details
although the project
of the project all recommended planning
conditions therefore with electric
vehicle charging coins low level
lighting traffic calming
we're going over and beyond what would
normally be expected
we have no objection to your ecologist
environmental health
and county highways and therefore uh
we lead your planning officers i
recommend this application for approval
uh thank you very much lovely well done
gents that was very seamless well done
you
um if you could stay on the line just
for a second we do have two questions
for you so counselor dixon first if
you'd like to ask your question
uh thank you chairman uh it may be an
unfair question to yourself but you did
make reference to it and our planning
officer in their presentation did not
in the report our sdc street scene
indicate that the location of the
proposed bin collection point
does not meet our requirements have you
any comments please
well we have a big collection point
that's neatly put to one side
halfway along the access road and the
walking distance
this are reasonable from the highway and
from the dwellings themselves
we you know we're talking about 15 or 20
meters in each direction
and this is entirely reasonable when
referring to manual for streets
thank you i'll uh pose the same question
back to our planning offices thank you
thank you thank you gents and councillor
para you have a question
thank you chair actually uh uh
councillor dixon's stolen my thunder
because i
couldn't quite i was trying to i wanted
to have greater clarity on where this
been
um been receptacle
area was was placed and and it's not
particularly clear on the map that i can
see on the screen
but if it is um because i'm i'm
concerned about the length of
the the access drive to the property
to the bins i just wanted to know the
length from the applicant
from the house to the bin store and then
from the bin store to the road
well uh it obviously depends on which
house you're in
but uh we are talking roughly 25 meters
as a maximum walking distance for the
residents
to that bin collection area and at 25
meters or thereabouts
for the refuse collection operatives
so we feel it it's reasonable
we would perhaps prefer it there as
opposed to
placing wheelie bins on the footwear
where they can obviously cause problems
for
you know pedestrians and the less able
so the collection point just
behind the footweight it seems to be a
sensible thing to do
thank you okay we'll we'll probably
confirm that with the case officer
shortly as well
um i see no further questions from
members so uh gentlemen thank you very
much uh for your time
um feel free to hang out and continue to
watch on our online portal
um so we have
our ward member here as well um who is
going to speak so counselor edin
you have five minutes i will give you a
30 second warning feel free to use as
much or as little of those five minutes
as you like
over to you thank you sarah do you have
my photo you perfect
beat me to it okay uh i'll just
i'll come to those in a minute and and
we'll talk through them
okay so thank you very much um firstly
i'd like to back up
the parish council's opinions on the
site uh i think they're very well
rounded
um overall personally i think that the
layout and the design of the site or
proposed
design the size poor the sweat path
diagram which wasn't on the officer's
presentation shows very tight
maneuvering for the vehicles based on
the proposed parking layout
the probable demographic for usage i
realize it's perhaps slightly
speculative but we should probably air
towards protecting the future residents
with good access and as much assistance
and protection
as we can realistically offer
the idea of taking bins along a long
unlit road with no path
worries me massively and the office
report does also mention that this is
not
ideal problems with the access and
egress are one of the biggest issues
and whilst highways haven't objected
probably because it is an existing set
of garages
the road is effectively single
carriageway with multiple pinch points
nearby due to parked cars and pulling
out even a nose
blindly is likely to cause an accident
at some point so
if the committee is so minded to grant i
ask that you have some conditions to
improve the
visibility splainly so in terms of the
photos sarah
so this is actually mimics the one that
you showed us so this is the length of
the drive looking down
if you could scroll to the next one
please
thank you so this is the view from the
footpath looking
left up the road but you can see clearly
the row of parked cars this was taking
about half five of an evening
so probably quite a few people home at
that point but it is effectively single
single carriageway there with with some
passing points and then the final photo
please sarah
thank you so this is the visibility
the opposite direction pulling out of
the drive so this is the overgrown hedge
or the hedge
of the neighbours i guess um and you can
see that
there are cars parked out onto the road
where that van is
the visibility is virtually nothing and
and you'd be meeting single traffic
on your side of the road in the
direction
um so to summarize my thoughts uh i
don't have an issue with
with the notion of two very welcome
bungalows in the area
as the applicant alluded to they are
part of our emerging neighborhood
development plan
and our housing needs survey i just feel
that the layout design could be improved
and would also ask
members to fully consider the
possibility of conditioning
some low level or solar lighting along
the length of the drive
and particularly improvements to the
visibility display
from the entrance and that's it thank
you very much
wonderful thank you counselor adam well
within your time uh council dixon has a
question for you councillor dixon
thank you chairman council redden um are
the garages or when will the garages
last in use
um given that we're talking about access
and egress from the site
um two bungalows possibly one car each
maybe actually less than the number of
garages and the
viewpoint in the access from the
entrance it would presumably be exactly
the same as it was when
cars were up and down there to the
garages
uh to be honest counselor i don't know
the exact date but clearly from the
office's photographs they haven't been
in use for quite a long time
um in terms of traffic uh i i don't have
the answer so i can't give you an
accurate
one i'm afraid thank you
okay lovely i i can see no one else
looking for a question i'll give you a
couple of seconds guys if you want to
ask
a question
i'm it looks like that's going to be a
no so councillor thank you
very much uh for your contribution uh
over to
uh questions and technical uh uh
points of clarification to the officers
councillor parry is in the first
accounts against barry
thank you very much um chairman um
i wonder whether the officers can give
greater
information on the space available for
these
i need more clarity on these bins
uh and where they're being proposed
because if there are
two dwellings we're looking like we're
looking at six
six bins and the width and if it's a
single track
i'm just trying to get my head around
where they're gonna go
having seen the photograph so i would
welcome some clarity
that all those bins six bins
sort of down the road
um could the officer explain exactly
what format would they be in yes
certainly so um day-to-day the bins
would be stored in the rear gardens of
the properties
i i'm not sure if members can see my
cursor but the
bin stores are just below the tree in
the garden of plot two and then the top
left hand corner in plot one
that's a cycle and bin store there so
then on collection day the collection
point
is um halfway up the driveway just next
to
the garage for number 16 watts road
um it's not hugely large but obviously
on collection day you're not putting all
your bins out at once um
depending on the day uh you know the
recycling day that it is
um it's considered sufficient for the
amount of bins that two houses would
generate
um the the space on the side of the road
doesn't appear very wide on the
photographs but we can see the red line
does allow quite a amount of verge there
which the hedge could be trimmed back
on the applicant's side um allowing
space to store the bins
off the road that's bin collection point
is just less than 15 meters from the
carriageway so it meets the guidance
in manual for streets in that respect
for the bin operatives to collect it
it's slightly further as the applicant
has said um
for the resident to put the bins at the
collection point
um i haven't measured it but going from
the distance from the road to the bin
point is just less than 15 meters
to get to plot two would be slightly
more than that and then as the applicant
has said to plot one it's probably more
like 25
whilst that is slightly over the
guidance in manual for streets it's not
considered unreasonable
um given the circumstances and it's
fine from the point of view of the bin
operatives
um i hope that answers the question
lovely thank you very much um council
barry did you have a
follow-up well no i just i i would like
to
if the bin stores are in the rear garden
and if we take where the proposed bin
store of 15 meters is
there is more than 50 meters from there
to the end of that drive point
and then there's at least an so
basically
um the occupants
of the properties have got a wheel heavy
bins
six well certainly 30 to 40 meters
to get it to the bin store would i would
that be a fair assumption
if the applicant chooses to store the
bins in the bin store
in the rear garden in the far corner of
plot one then yes it might be that
distance
to take it to the bin collection point i
suppose there is some balancing exercise
to be done in that there is a site which
is currently vacant and
in many respects suitable for housing
slight downside is a slightly longer
carry distance for the resident
um which which is a slight downside but
as you say there's a balancing exercise
to be done there
if i could just add to that obviously
also any purchasers would be aware of
that situation would make any purchase
on that basis if that was very important
to them then they might decide that's
not the property for them
okay uh counselor physic you have a
question
thank you chair um on the map what is
the space
to the right of p1 parking you can see
there's a gay entrance
to it yeah so
you can see two gay entrances um
one which is into the rear garden of
number 16
watts road and then the other
is to the rear of the property on that
side of the boundary that's number 33
and don't recall the road name but that
is an access to
another property i have a photograph
which shows it in a
bit more detail
sarah i think your microphone muted
itself somehow
apologies i'm just flipping to a
photograph
i'm just every time i try to change
slide it
mutes myself i'm just trying to change
slides
to show you those entrances so you can
see them in the corner of this
photograph here
both residents have actually built sheds
in front of their access
um but the applicant has no intention of
blocking off these accesses
and i've got a reserved slide at the end
here which
shows um that you can maneuver into and
out of those accesses should you wish
they're not being blocked
by the application thank you
lovely thank you very much i don't see
any further questions for clarification
so
we will move straight into the debate
who would like to go first
don't all jump at once
i think counselor parry might be typing
so i will save her fingers cancel parry
please
when you're ready
i was hoping somebody else might dive in
but there we go
um number one i don't like the design of
this
particular development um but and i
don't like the long drive
but obviously with no objection from
highways
um i'm afraid i can't see any
material planning reasons to refuse this
application
um i don't like where the bin stores are
um am i um i do share but counselor
eden's views but i'm afraid on a
material
planning reason i can't i can't
personally see
a valid reason to refuse
okay i think i'm inclined to agree with
you um counselor adam has indicated he'd
like to speak so before i do i will let
him come in first
counselor adam thank you chairman um i
was going to
um agree with uh councillor harry's um
summing up
there i think it's quite difficult
because there are arguably
issues and and the concerns raised by
the war member and the parish council
are perfectly valid
but i am struggling to find valid
planning reasons to
um to put anything against it
uh and so i'd be happy to second that
um
okay thank you very much we didn't
actually have a proposal for councillor
parry but on the basis of what has been
said and i'm in agreement with you all i
will propose
that we do grant in line with the
officer's recommendation however i would
um i just want to ask a question about
conditions that the
award member um asked about condition
for the visibility displays
um i i of course note that we have had
no objection from the highways obviously
i can only assume that they are happy
that the visibility displays meet the
minimum standards
but if we could add in a condition that
reinforces that
um that might be helpful is that
something we can do
sarah um i'm unsure about that one
chairman richard might want to weigh in
here but i think
part of the issue um the parish council
and
member may have with the visibility is
the large hedge that is on the left is
leaving the site
if that is in the membership in the
ownership of the neighbour i'm not sure
what kind of
control we could have over that richard
do you have anything to add
um yeah if if that hedges in third party
ownership
it's possible to put a condition on
requiring visibility display
but then um it's effectively what's
known as a gram pain condition and
you're requiring works to be done on
third-party land
so it is borderline unreasonable to do
that
but without knowing what the required
visibility display
is it's hard to say all we know is as it
stands county highways are happy with it
okay um if it's unreasonable to add it
then i'm happy for it
uh not to be put on there um counselor
harry i think you you wanted to add
something
yes i'm i mean obviously the the layout
and design of the site is quite unusual
with this very very long
um access drive and councillor eden
made a very valid suggestion about
putting forward some solar
um lighting or just some element because
if
particularly um if you consider the
residents have got to go and wheel their
bins all the way down now it's fine in
the summer months but
you know if you're if if it's dark at
five o'clock and you've gone to work
and then you've got a wheel you'll bend
back up to your property
um i think it would be prudent to have
some form of
very subtle low lighting if that's if
that's a possible consideration by the
planning officers
yes i think we'd be happy with that i
think we'd want details prior to
implementation of that just so that it's
not um you know disturbance for the
residents make sure that it's in
proportion to the need
in terms of light levels and things um
but that sounds
reasonable to me richard
so um i would question whether it meets
the test of necessity because the
concern obviously arises from
its the new owners whether it's a
problem for them if it was a problem for
them they put solar lights in
is it something that the planning
authority wants to control or just leave
it to the owners if
if it's not a problem for them they
carry a torch or something like that
perhaps
i'll come in at that point i i i think
you've more or less said well i was
going to say that uh richard that um
it may be that the new owners want to
have a nice dark driveway so that they
can
be left in peace and quiet in their
little little area
um but if they do want to add lights
they can have that uh those low level
lighting at a later stage so i'm
i'm not inclined to add that condition
um my proposal is um
to grant in line with us officer's
recommendation the conditions
set out in the report in the update
sheet um i will seek
a second that please
and if i don't ah here we go i i now
have councillor adam second in first a
council adam do you want to say anything
or are you happy just a second
i'm happy just a second thank you
fabulous councillor fifa you've also
noted in there do you want to speak to
secondly or are you happy for us to go
straight to the vote uh let's crack on
and same with you councillor dixon
straight to the boat chairman
fabulous okay in that case i will start
um councillor richards
four thank you chairman councillor adam
counter adam four councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you
councillor fitter
councillor for and councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you
that's unanimous for chairman thank you
very much liz so
uh committee therefore resolves to grant
application twenty zero zero five six
one f u
l in line with the officer's report in
the update sheet we will take
a one minute adjournment while we bring
in our final speakers for the final item
and then we will get straight to it
please microphones
okay we have all our speakers here so uh
members we are back um and we are now
considering application
reference twenty zero one two eight two
ful that's a quarter
deck on uh the water um bankrupt basin
at waterside in stratford
our presenting officer is sarah chadwick
sarah whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chairman you just get the
powerpoint
is everyone able to see that
okay perfect yes yeah thank you okay
thank you sherman this is a full
planning application for an ancillary
seating area and associated fencing
on the footpath to the east of the
bargain quarter deck cafe badge
the application site is within the
adopted built-up area boundary of
stratford-upon-avon
outlined by the red line on this plan
the barge to which the proposed
development is related is located to the
west of the red line area
seen here
here we see a proposed floor plan of the
application site
the site is within the bancroft gardens
area in the town centre
the site is also within the conservation
area and an area of restraint
an existing seating area is located to
the west of the barge within the canal
basin
on timber decking which can be seen here
with the barge in the center
and this is the proposed area of seating
on the path
here we see proposed elevations of the
development and elevational details of
the proposed fencing
which is chrome bar with blue pvc panels
now onto site photos this photo taken
facing in a northeast direction shows
the existing seating area on decking
within the canal basin located to the
west of the barge
this image is taken facing in a northern
direction showing the area where the
proposed
development would be located on the
footpath here
the seating area would extend 2.9 metres
onto the pathway
leaving 1.2 meters for pedestrian access
this photo is taken place in a southwest
direction with the grade 2 star listed
raw shakespeare theater visible in the
background here
chairman the principle of development is
acceptable however officers can consider
that the proposed development would have
a harmful impact on the bancroft gardens
area
by way of sprawl decreased connectivity
and the creation of a private area
within the public realm contrary to
policies within the development plan
by extension this is considered to cause
harm to the strategic conservation area
which is not outweighed by any public
benefit
the recommendation is therefore to
refuse the application for the reasons
detailed in page 44 of your agenda
thank you sarah that's very concise
thank you very much
we will move straight to our first
speaker who is mr
colin pike uh the in fact he's the
applicant
uh mr pike are you there you may need to
press star and six to unmute your
phone hello can you hear me
we can indeed welcome mr pike um thank
you you have
you have three minutes i will give you a
30 second warning before your time is up
and whenever you're ready please go
okay good evening and i'd like to start
by saying thank you for letting me speak
um i'm a long-established business owner
within the town centre and a director of
waterborne limited the company that owns
the bargain call today
this application is consistent with
other approved schemes in the immediate
area
that have since been approved have since
proved to be both successful and popular
these outside seating areas share the
same conservation area
which is the same area of restraint
occupied main pedestrian thoroughfares
which are also public spaces
adjacent to a busy road are of similar
design to this proposal
and are in use all year round in
addition one is placed directly outside
a grade two listed building
by contrast this application site is not
listed
it's for seasonal use only and is
located on a little use pavement that is
well away from the road
the pavement in question is very much an
ancillary one within the bancroft
because it serves no other purpose
than to provide a secondary public
access to the barging quarter deck
the primary one being from the other
side of the boat by the deck
surrounding pavements within the
bankrupt take up the vast majority of
football because they follow the main
desire lines
or pedestrian flows was correctly
identified as part of the world-class
stratford consultation
15 years ago following on from which the
pavement layouts in the bancroft were
changed as part of the following
redevelopment works
with tables and chairs and situ there
will be no need pedestrians to go onto
the adjacent grassed areas as there is
enough space on the pavement given the
1.2 metre clear width
and the two full pavement width openings
extending to nearly 5.5 meters
in length to allow for any busy
pedestrian flows
it is not in the interest of this
business to harm the adjacent griped
areas
which are fully open to the public and
in regular use
this proposal represents an attractive
and natural extension to a
well-established highly popular
successful
local independent business which buys
locally wherever possible employ
and employs a growing number of people
which is all good for the local economy
this proposal is very much of its time
given the current situation and the
widespread support about outside seating
spaces for rateable businesses in
general
however if refused it would place this
business at a competitive disadvantage
to similar offers in the immediate areas
which has which is potentially very
harmful given the particular
the current situation this site has
always been
highly regulated by both stratfor
district council and the canal and river
trust
meaning there are many legal controls
and balances in place
it is a long established and highly
regarded business that has evolved
steadily and surely
under the same ownership for 18 years
for a period of 25 years following
significant personal
investment to upgrade the business to
its current layout
i'm happy to answer any questions you
may have and thank you for listening
fantastic thank you mr pike members do
we have any questions
for the applicant
i don't see any hands going up or any
anything in the chat so mr pike thank
you
very much for for dining in your
contributions tonight feel free to hang
up and continue to watch
uh on the online portal thank you we
will move
thank you we will move to our next
speaker who is councillor fragili
councillor francis welcome you've been
very patient this evening thank you
i've enjoyed the show guys you've got
five minutes we'll give you 30 second
warning whenever you're ready
thank you very much chair as ward
councillor for guild hall where the
quarter deck is moored
i'm in total support of this application
i've not supported other applications
for this site but i see this as a
positive addition
to the offer to residents and visitors
of our town
i note from the papers that the sdc
consider
the proposed development is acceptable
except for the issues which they have
raised
the county council has no objection
environmental agency no objection
uh wcc ecology no objection canal canal
and river trust no objection
and the town uh council raises no
objection
this is a local business owned by a
local businessman
employ 11 local people on the existing
boat
with an opportunity if extended to
employ further staff
in the busy season every effort is made
by this company to source food locally
uh within a 10 mile radius of the town
these additional eight tables umbrellas
and barrier
are temporary and will be removed march
to october
so these are not permanent features in
this small corner
of a busy bancroft i have observed the
foot traffic here over the last few busy
days
and although the path is used it is not
very busy
and there are many other options
including flat glass area
grass area adjacent which is often
preferred by families walking across
here
the pavement space left will be 1.2
meters
the tables are situated in a corner made
by two barges at right angles
and so reduces their prominence on the
bancroft
the business enhances the vibrancy of
the area
and according to policy be2 does
does make a positive contribution to the
local character
as this is an entirely local business in
fact i think it is quite suitable as the
business is situated on a barge
this is a boat pound and it's on the
site of a boat pound
and it's also on the side of what was
historically
a very busy uh business area
i take issue with the comment in
paragraph five in the papers
read the gradual erosion of the
character of the bancroft
when random tables and chairs uh
installed throughout the year by the
market do sometimes spill into this area
there is a silver coffee bean installed
by the rsc
and the only other random object since
the bancroft was remodeled
earlier this century is the statue of
young will
it would be a simple matter to condition
the exclusion
of graphics or the color of the sheeting
in fact
i see no reason for she effort for
a prominent barrier to be placed here at
all
in these exceptionally harsh times for
small independent
uh businesses we should be encouraging
an enterprise such as this we should not
be putting up barriers to it
policy e3 and the ndp would seek to
support such local businesses
in fact with the government's recent uh
promote pronouncements
on cafes being able to use pavements
with uh
more extensively with with local
permission i don't see why this business
couldn't actually
ask to use that pavement as in an ad hoc
way
during the um pandemic and the uh and
the uh
change in in government instructions
it is temporary it is a local business
it supports local enterprise
it supports visitors and locals and i
would sincerely ask
the uh committee to approve this
application
thank you very much for that you have a
couple of questions lined up so
counselor parry first
please good evening councillor fragilian
thank you for being so patient
um i'm not um as familiar with the
specific
location as you will be in terms of
regularly walking or cycling around that
area obviously this this particular area
is probably used also by um
disabled motorized scooters and that
sort of thing
what are your views in terms of the
space
that would be remain or alternative
routes
that people in disabled scooters or
wheelchairs could could access that
area um well when i was actually
observing it i did watch it
not on a motorized scooter but i did
watch a family with a
with a buggy walking along there and
they actually pushed the buggy
off the path because they were following
their younger children onto the path
so there would be access onto onto that
grass area
but there are other paved paths which
can
access this area by going at a slight
diagonal
and then turning back along the path at
the side of the boat pound
which is lined with with barges which
has one barge there
not right well there are two you know
two barges there
lovely thank you counselor adam
thank you and thank you counselor
gradually and what you still was raised
by the conservation officer was
um that this might encourage similar
development in the vicinity now i know
the area
relatively well can you think of other
businesses
that might seek to do the same in this
immediate area i mean from what i can
see that's
there's some distance to the buildings
other businesses on the canal
that might do did you do something
similar well there are businesses that
actually on barges that there are barges
which sell
um drinks and ice creams there's a barge
there which actually offers
evening and daytime trips uh with meals
on board
which moore's there so there are other
businesses
um from barges in that area this is
actually also gonna be slightly more
sedentary because it's going to put
it would like to put tables in this area
but when you actually look at it from if
you're standing by the river
and you look up across the bank off on a
busy day
you'd actually hardly see this because
there's so much going on the trees and
people moving around there are deck
chairs
i think it's controlled uh business
there for tinkers or anybody else and
i've
never seen any um carts selling coffee
or anything i think that would be
excluded okay thank you um i
i have a quick question if i may um uh
the money for streets indicates we need
a minimum of two meters
uh of of space um we've only got 1.2
in since if if this were to be granted
and we've also got an objection from our
conservation officer
have you got um a robust and clear
reason why we should go against
the manufacturing our own conservation
officer
i think the main reason is that we need
to um
be upping our offer to both residents
and to visitors
and there are pathways there which can
easily be used by people
who are um who are using buggies
i think the space for somebody who is
actively work walking is wide enough but
it would be difficult for somebody in in
a motorized buggy but there are other
alternatives okay lovely thank you very
very much
um i see no other questions so council
fragi thank you very much feel free to
stay on and watch the
the last bits of the debate do you have
any questions for the officer
no should we move straight to the debate
who would like to start
no one i'll go then um
so this is i find this quite difficult
and
i i really want to support um uh
the application but we do have uh a
for streets that indicates minimum two
meters and
we must be adhering to that manual for
streets particularly given
uh there will inevitably be uh people
in uh either wheelchairs or motorized
buggies and what have you need to move
up and down whilst there are
alternatives we do go against our money
for streets and we also have an
objection from our um
conservation officer um i haven't yet
heard
a planning reason why we should go
against those two
um two points and grant so um
with regret that i will be proposing
that we do go with our officer's
recommendation and refuse
the application as set out i will look
for a second
uh counselor adam
thank you chairman um one of the things
i note in the
officers report which causes me some
sort of consternation around this
is um the is from the conservation
officer essentially suggesting that
um this would be uncoordinated street
furniture and clutter
surely the the purpose of putting in a
planning permission
is to ensure that it isn't uncoordinated
and make sure that it is
um within what we are trying to set out
um as control for for the area um
i i also have some um
some concerns around the the width um
has set out a 1.2 and just whether the
um the two meter minimum
set out for the manual for streets is
the only um relevant
uh document that we'd use for that as um
i'm aware that public rights of way next
to fields and things is 1.5
um and that there may be options for
for other allowances
that would be closer to the mark as
what's shown
given that um we are trying to
to support local businesses of which
this is
um a well-respected and
uh long-term one in the district i can't
um support the officer's recommendations
to refuse on this
um i'm i'm but i would like to to
try and get a measure of of the rest of
the committees used before i am
before i put any proposal to to go
against that
okay thank you you've um there were two
points you made though about the the
conservation comments i think that's
probably subjective so
um obviously i appreciate that people
have different views with the money for
streets i
wonder if we can ask um our planning
manager richard gardner to come in and
just talk to us about that one
that two meter versus the 1.2 and if
there are any other policies that can be
applied in this instance
certainly yeah um that the actual site
isn't within
highway lands a manual for streets
doesn't strictly apply
but it does provide useful guidance to
an appropriate width for
what is effectively a pavement here
because if uh
buggies and scooters all that kind of
thing i can't
go on the the hard standing they're
forced onto the grass which can be muddy
at some times of the year
um so it does provide a useful yardstick
uh but nonetheless
um there is the issue it's a busy area
and people would wish to
try and stick to the pavements at times
and therefore
um the the two meter width is is um
in office's view a sensible one to to
have and this would impose on that
okay lovely thank you very much
councillor parry you're in the case
you'd like to speak
thank you chair um i i
certainly hear what uh councillor adam
has to say
and i'm also mindful that the
conservation officer will have will have
come to these various conclusions before
the government introduced a bill on the
pavement licensing
situation where we've got i appreciate
this is not
um highway pavement um
because it's public realm but in terms
of the
um conservation officers comments on
clutter and that sort of thing
um because the government have
introduced this pavement
licensing bill um we're going to find in
the conservation area
various restaurants and
food service providers um applying for
a pavement license where we will have
very little control
over what they're actually going to be
putting
in terms of tables and chairs and how
it's going to look
um and i was just actually looking for a
bit more guidance on the
temporary measures that um
could could be introduced the council of
fragile talked about this being
temporary obviously between
march and october um i perhaps should
have come on this on the
officers uh technical questions but i
would
welcome just a little bit of guidance on
the
the nature of the temporary measures
that have been spoken about this evening
okay um i don't know who would like to
come in on that whether that would be
yourself sarah or whether richard would
like to come in on it
who would like
the application is is um it's a
permanent application so if it were
granted
it would be forever but it's a seasonal
use so it'd be forever
from march to october i think it is each
year so that's what you
that's what you'd be looking at it would
be possible
um it it's within your gift to um
granted temporary permission it's not
what they've applied for so you could
run the temperature
for three years for instance so three
seasons
in effect but you'd need some planning
reasons as to why you were putting that
caveat on
uh and that might be to see how it pans
out with with the bancroft and the
narrowness of the footpath something
like that
uh but i wouldn't strongly recommend
that course
okay that's um okay a temporary was
something that was in my mind i'll come
to that in a second but first
cancer dixon you've indicated you have a
question to the planners
thank you chairman uh councillor pally
really brought the subject up i was
wondering how the
impact was between this and street
trading treat licenses etc
so essentially it's been covered thank
you
okay good um does anyone else want to
come in at this point anyone that hasn't
already spoken
don't jump at once
i'm having listened to the debate
and heard people's views as i said it
was
with regret that i was proposing that we
refused
i wonder now having listened to what's
been said
um and particularly the point that was
made about the
uh manual for streets not specifically
being
applicable here but being a good guide
whether members would be inclined to
grant on a temporary basis on a
three-year basis
and the reason for that um is to
support the business um
having been obviously been through uh
the pandemic pandemic that we've gone
through to give them the support
but also to then see how uh
this this proposal does impact the
bancroft gardens in particular the
pavements
my biggest concern of the pavement is
whether or not a wheelchair and or
an accessibility vehicle would be able
to get up and down it
we would be able to tell that if we have
it on a temporary basis
um if members are inclined to agree with
me on that i'm
happy to make a proposal on that basis
but i will wait to hear from from
everyone else
um councillor fitter you've indicated
you'd like to speak yeah thank you chair
um i would completely agree with you
there
and also just reading uh some of the key
issues on the
agenda cs22 talked about the economic
development and
in my opinion i think this would be a
fantastic addition to that and also uh
the neighborhood development plan
policy e3 talks about tourism etc
uh when i go into town center the last
time i was out i was actually sunbathing
on the bit of grass next to it
and it would be a lovely area for these
tables so um
i'd be happy to propose the temporary
permission
for this
okay excellent um i will second you in
that case
uh i can see councillor parry has has
indicated you want to speak to to what
you've said there counselor parry or are
you happy to
to move on towards a vote no i'm happy
to move on to a vote chairman
same question to you counselor adam yeah
likewise i'm happy to move on to the
vote
okay uh in that case the proposal is to
grant the application on a three-year
temporary
basis um and by the way just in case
there's some confusion i did put a
proposal to refuse earlier
i am rescinding that proposal and
therefore seconding counselor fitters
just in case there's any confusion
so the proposal is to grant for a
three-year temporary basis
um if we could go through
do we need to talk about any conditions
at this point uh richard or are you
happy for us to go through to a roll
call
um it would help uh
[Music]
perhaps if uh we've got yeah there's two
issues as conditions and also
if members are granting it what the
reason for overturning it is um
so perhaps if i um i don't know whether
it's best to wait until the
you've voted and then um perhaps yeah
no perhaps ask now what if members are
asking to grant it
what the reason is because at the moment
you've got a recommendation with
harm to heritage assets that to my mind
there's two ways that you could steer a
path around that
you could simply say there's no harm to
heritage assets and therefore the
scheme's acceptable
or if you find this harm to heritage
assets then you need to find public
benefits
and i've already heard that there's
economic benefits and issues relating to
covid that may
constitute that so there's two ways you
could do it but i just need to know
which you've
chosen the latter of those two would
have been my reason
but given council of peter made a
proposal i will ask him to
to come in at that yeah um
mine would be that there is um yeah the
the economic benefits and
uh kobit et cetera i'll put that as the
uh the reasoning for us to get around
that
okay and presumably that would also
underpin the reason for having a
three-year condition
not only to monitor it and see how the
economy pans out in three years
yeah exactly exactly right council can
review it right okay
so then just moving on to conditions
you've got the temporary condition
i'd recommend an approved plans
condition and also the seasonal use
condition
march to october i'm fine with that
council are you fine with that uh yes
thank you chair
fabulous okay i think we've got that
sorted so let's move to a vote um so the
vote is to grant on a temporary basis
for the reasons given
uh i will go first councillor richards
four thank you chairman
councillor adam councillor adam four
councillor dixon councillor dixon four
thank you councillor eden council
reading
for councillor fitter councillor theater
four and councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you that's
unanimous chairman
wonderful uh in that case um committee
uh resolved to grant on a temporary
basis
application number twenty zero one two
eight two f u
l uh we have no further business no
urgent business
so uh i will thank you all for your
contributions particularly our officers
for their help throughout this
and we will call the meeting to a close
thank you very much everyone